[Music]
well hey everybody what's going on yep
it's Friday night it's my favorite show
of the week
yeah got my two-tone hair on again yeah
which I also had on yesterday when I did
the um if you didn't see I put up a book
review yesterday of slooh foot by what
day is New Year's Monday Monday okay
Monday's New Year's Day okay so Sunday
night would be New Year's Eve right I
wonder what's going on New
Year's uh I don't know Amateur hour but
Amur yeah that's that's what that's what
drunks like us call New Year's Eve and
St Patrick's Day and St
goo Amateur hour because that's when the
people who don't usually drink all that
much go out and drink a [__] ton yeah
and start Behaving Badly so you know
we're used to it
yeah so looks like everybody's starting
to roll in they're just pouring in as
soon as the [__] starts going Zach's in
what's up Zach what's up John Smith
what's up Sebastian filbert Grim II
third looking good it's been a while
thank you you guys look great well thank
you very much I'm sure you look great
also even though I can't see you um but
yeah I don't know yet it has been a
while since you've been here so I don't
even
remember I don't even remember how long
ago it
was you know you've been on hormones for
a long time but I've only been on
hormones for not that long who's saying
so maybe no no no I just said that oh
okay I just said that what's it have to
do with remember or anything because
they were saying like um I can't read it
look like looking good it's been a while
you guys look great so I was just maybe
assuming that you you get where I'm
going with that I was maybe assuming
that yeah I don't know we hit I don't
know dud thinking G thanks okay thanks
for helping me out he may be he not may
he may not be talking about that well I
don't know like I said it might have
been been a while our hormonal
assistance our hormonal assistance yeah
our hormone replacement
therapy Zach says it's my mom's birthday
today well happy birthday to your mom
says and my mom doesn't like her
birthday for reasons I'm sure you can
imagine I mean I'm well I'm getting old
but I still like my birthday because you
get cake and [__] so you
know uh Tammy's here hey Tammy Alison
Wonderland said drinking a [__] ton here
all right man we just we just got
started just got started we're drinking
it's so I mean it's 7:30 vodka and Tiki
Punch Yeah we didn't like Tom was like
well maybe I should go down and get some
more mixers but he's like but I do have
this two liter of tiki punch I was just
like well [__] that'll go yeah that'll
go with the Vodka it's good I like it
yeah it's not bad I got the flavored
vodka it might be good in there too oh
that's right yeah we got some flavored
vodka for
Christmas yeah what flavor is again
pineapple mango mango yeah that probably
go good in there something like that it
might go good in
there we'll try
it what's up uh there's another Zach in
here Zach 0057 saying hello so hello it
must be bu Zack oh right right right
yeah that's who you were talking to oh
okay right yeah that's the same Zack I'm
talking about it's a guy I met online
couple days ago we were uh fighting with
this idiot over over [__] bu ztl 3
breaks I guess there three or four
breaks seriously you were fighting over
motorcycle brakes no me and him were
fighting a guy oh well no that's what I
meant motorcyc generally this a kid he's
never even ritten a motorcycle he didn't
have a motorcycle all right I got two
bules Zach's got two bus this is
straight Zack not gay Zack we got
another Z okay so so now we're that's
how we're going to have to disting stra
Z gay
Zack Zach's got a [__] if it's if
it's if it's bu
Zack he's got a u a bu xb12 SS that's
[__] sweet yeah that's him yeah okay
and this
fantastic bule 1190 brand new bu 1190 I
think's a [__] super bike man fast as
[__] damn near 200 horsepower way
nothing good bike man great bike just a
extremely uprated 1120 or 1125 we used
to have those a long time ago the old
1125 are kind of [__] funny looking
crawfish but
um yeah the new the new ones are [__]
great I want to get one of the bu the
new bu 1190 super Cruiser it weighs only
400 pound nearly 200 pound it looks like
a dam Harley Davidson [__] uh looks
like Harley-Davidson Softtail [__]
funny
looking Philbert says yeah I remember he
has a friend that's a biker and promised
to show him off looking good with the
facial hair is what so it has been a
while I guess because you've had the
facial hair for a while yeah I've had
I've had beard for a while it's been a
while yeah yeah cuz I remember when you
were talking about growing that and I
was like I don't know how I feel about
it but you
know now I I like it though I like it
yeah I wasn't sure if I would but I do
like it look being the merciless you do
kind of yeah the funny thing now is that
people that haven't known you that long
yeah like only know like only know you
like that so when they see pictures of
you without any facial hair which you
know the whole yeah the whole time I
knew you you mostly had hair and facial
hair people are like what the [__] like
[__] that Su you look really weird yeah
it look friendly it look friendly with
[__] hair with now you look like a
mean [__] you look like a mean
[__]
yeah I kind of am though which you are
kind of well I don't well no not to just
random people you got you got to deserve
it well I think that's true of me as
well yeah Zach says uh no she hates her
birthday cuz it's right between
Christmas and New Year's yeah that does
kind of suck although I will say that
it's better than having your your
birthday on actual Christmas New Year's
it wouldn't really matter because it's
like you know everybody nobody's getting
presents on New Year's but uh you know
yeah uh John Smith said you look kind of
more like Anton Le yeah yeah I think
that's kind of more you were going you
were looking you want to look kind of
like Sinister no I just wanted to look
better as a bald
guy yeah yeah I got sick of having hair
my my hair qual quality once I started
pushing 50 my hair quality wasn't that
good and I was like [__] it I'm going to
shave this [__] hair off and uh I was
already getting kind of jacked so it
makes more sense and then if you're just
bald and you don't have any facial hair
then you look kind of [__] silly as
[__] you you kind of look like an egg
your head looks like an egg depending on
what your face looks like if you have a
real thin face you can get away with it
I think yeah you know what I mean yeah
so then I just started [__] do a
little [__] coair [__] beard like
a French Corsair beard and think they
call it [__] what do they call they
call it I think they call it a goatee I
guess I I thought a goatee was just like
was just that I looked it up though what
a goatee is and they did show this P
this one but that's not the way it used
that's not what it used to be called I
think go was just just yeah that's what
I thought I think there's a different
yeah okay so what's a van djk I don't
know maybe that one's like pointed but I
thought that was more like that style
but I could be totally wrong about that
too one of the old definitions names for
it was called a French Corsair beard
okay well that's what I'm going to call
it then because that's a rad name yeah
Corsair how's your French Corsair Tom
yeah yeah but I think the name I think
the name's just changed with time yeah
you know cuz that is kind of an old
timey name but that's why I like it it
was a pirate
beard okay well yeah that's cool too
yeah but it was this and you were bald
yeah cuz you know on a ship that's
[__] way you want you actually want
to be bald there was filthy on a [__]
well and also there's a lot of [__] your
[__] hair could get caught in which
is not fun for anyone yeah I've told you
a million times I wish I look good bald
because my hair is a giant [__] pain
in the ass your hair looks good though
your hair looks good well it looks good
but it's just kind of like I don't know
like I said my it's kind of long and
that's why I keep it usually shaved
underneath and I only have like well
this is a wig obviously but it's just
kind of like um you know so I just have
the top and the bangs because when it's
all grown
out it's really really thick but it's
also like each hair is like super fine
it's like baby hair and seriously
anytime if I run my fingers through it
like a bunch of it comes out but it
never seems to get any uh less dense so
I have hair all over the [__] place
you can run and Tom vacuum's in here all
the time but it's like I can run my foot
like along the carpet like in my office
and stuff and I will have like a big
[__] ball of hair and it's my hair
it's not cat hair so you know what I
mean it's just I shed everywhere it's
crazy and I have to keep [__]
plunging the drains out and stuff like
that because of all the hair but like I
said I don't look good bald otherwise I
would shave it all off because because I
don't like it I don't like it it's just
a pain Zach says I'm only 26 and I'm
already going gray I don't think that's
that uncommon yeah you're lucky to have
hair at 26 yeah a lot of guys that
actually I've known I knew I knew some
dudes um back in the day like when I was
you know a comparable age that were in
their 20s and stuff and we're starting
to like get receding hairlines and stuff
like that it's genetic it's really
there's not much you can do about it
unfortunately my [__] held out a long
time but uh started getting in my late
40s and you could start seeing that it
was starting to get thin in certain
areas and it just if it if it wasn't
perfect then it looked like [__] it got
to the point where you you I would dye
my hair just so it would [__] kind of
paint my scalp and it would look better
for a while you know then you're like
[__] what what am I doing I just [__]
shave the [__] off it's a lot better it
doesn't and you know and it's a lot less
maintenance too the thing is is that you
don't really want to be
bald if you're not in good shape if
you're fat it it kind of looks worse
sometimes depends on depends on you know
what you're going for well it depends on
the person it depends on the haircut
faces it works a little bit better but
you know I just [__] said [__] it I'm
going to go for the [__] tell suralis
[__] who loves you baby yeah who
loves you [__] Vin Diesel [__] um
y Breer they they were just [__]
bald and embra the Bal I had a decent
enough skull to to pull it off that's
what I mean you have a good head you
have that sounded dirty you have a nice
head pack of hot dog that also sounded
you don't have a pack of hot dogs back
there pack of almost like a look my
head's almost like a [__]
helmet got a helmet head
but uh it looked good it looked better
bald but it didn't quite look right I
added the beard and it it made more
sense which I say oh this is why guys
wear that yeah I do like it I like the
whole aesthetic so I decided well [__]
it it's Anton l or Ming the merciless
you know I could [__] make these
things [__] grow real long and
probably look ridiculous have [__]
Max von side out looked cool as [__]
though he did yeah yeah that dude was
that that [__] was sexy as [__]
well he pulled it off cuz he was th in
yeah and he looked good in those
uniforms that had him on I [__] love
the old Flash Gordon movie I thought it
was great I when it came out I thought
it was better than [__] Star Wars in
certain ways it had sex and drugs in it
yeah and hot chicks [__] and crazy
colors and [__] space that didn't
make sense but that's the what that was
what the source material was super fun
yeah and um and it was true to Source
material if you watch the old [__]
um uh Flash Gordon cereals it had sex
and drugs and it was pre-code I
think CU they were yeah it probably was
because they got away with a lot of
stuff in there that they would not have
been able to get away with had it been
at post Haze code the the sex wasn't
overt but pretty much I mean it was
pretty suggestive I was surprised and
Princess AA [__] trying to slip PE
slip people [__] Mickey you know love
drugs and [__] rui and yeah ruian people
and in the modern parlons yeah and then
like then her and Dale are fighting over
[__] Flash and he's like it's okay
guys we can all work something out
between yeah bet yeah you know there's
all kind of innuendos just lay down and
I will just lay between all of your
breasts yeah go get the go get me a
power potion and get some love pills and
we'll [__] work all this out which is
you know [__] you can both have me girls
power potion that's why fagra yeah you
know that's what we talking about
viagra yeah Viagra and ecstasy that's
what they're talking about uhhuh yeah
well like I said there's a lot of movies
and stuff and media from the 1930s that
is kind of like where they talk pretty
openly like about drugs and stuff like
that because a lot of them weren't
illegal that was kind of a later yeah
that was a later thing yeah well the
idea that drugs were some kind of
problem that's a new invention they just
took drugs back there
they did even during the 20s and 30s
they just took them yeah everybody was
taking that [__] well like I said a lot
of them even weren't even illegal yeah
Alison wond land said I dyed my hair
burgundy for the holidays that sounds
pretty I've had burgundy hair I've had
bright red hair I've had purple hair
I've had blonde hair like white blonde
hair for a little while um what other
colors have I done I did um black with
red bangs or red with black bangs now I
can't remember um I've done like lots of
different ones now it's just black
because that's just kind of but I have
thought about because I like that blue
wig that I have so much and because
every single time I wear the blue wig I
get like the most amount of compliments
people like man that blue wig that just
really suits you you know what I mean so
I'm thinking to myself maybe I should
just dye my actual hair blue but the
only downside to that is that I loved
when I had my bright red hair like it
looked so rad but the reason that it
looks rad was because I constantly
constantly had to put comb dye through
it and every single thing in the house
had like the shower was red the
pillowcases were red like every like the
towels were well our towels are well my
towels are like dark color dark colored
but it's just so everything got dye all
over it so I don't know I I don't know
I'll think about it okay so it looks
like uh the crowd is in this is
basically open lines Friday anything you
want to talk to us about any questions
for Jen some of the projects that she
has going on she's getting a new video
ready history of horror that'll be out
when's it gonna be out I'm gonna I'm
shooting for Monday but it because I
wanted to do it New Year's Day but I
might not make it we'll see yeah we'll
see what channel is that going to be
released on I can't decide what I mean
what do you think is better I kind of
feel like I should probably upload it to
the 13 o'clock Channel because we have
way more subscribers yeah but then on
the other hand I was thinking maybe I
should upload it to my scare Salon
Channel because maybe that would draw
more attention to that channel maybe why
don't you put it on scarce but yeah but
I'm not really sure because you guys
like if you wanted to see it you would
you know can you put them on both um you
maybe can but I think YouTube has a
thing where you can't upload the exact
same thing to both I mean I guess maybe
I could do two versions where I could I
I would I would put the main one on scar
Salon that's kind of what I was thinking
maybe upload an ad for it on this
channel oh that's a good idea just a
little quick see I'm dumb I didn't think
that I didn't think of that to divert
them to it I did like I wrote this big
long [__] it's a novela seriously
because I looked at the word count I'm
like I'm [__] I could [__] publish
this as a book but um I did a script
timer and the video is going to be at
least two hours I think it's going to be
two hours long but like I said if I
don't get it up on Monday it'll be soon
but because I don't want to rush it
because I want it to be good but I have
the scripture right now and I have like
little intros for each decade and all
that other kind of stuff I have those
done but I'm kind of still trying to
decide I'll probably just film myself
like I usually do for my book reviews
and stuff but then maybe have like half
of the screen like with images you know
what I mean of posters of all the movies
I'm talking about holy [__] I didn't
realize how long I started working on it
like a long time ago because I was going
to do it for Halloween um and then once
I got into it I think I got up to the
1980s and like in the essay and I was
like holy [__] [__] this is like a
massive undertaking um you know what I
mean and it just took me so long to
write and then I just had got busy with
other things and didn't get to it but I
was just like I really really want to
finish this like before the end of the
year or at least like you know in the
new thing of the year because it's
something I've been wanting to do like
for a really long time but you know what
I mean so hopefully hopefully um I'll
get up there um let me see hold on hold
on uh so they're talking about dyeing
their hairs different colors uh lavender
for sure yeah lavender though that'd be
pretty if you ever dye your hair another
another color take it back to that dab
red
you think I really did like that that
red was pretty good I mean it's like I
said it's very it's high maintenance cuz
I have to even when I don't wash it I
have to I would take like a little bit
of dye and like comb it through or put
it in the conditioner you know although
you do look good in that ice
blue yeah I really do like that but I
don't know if you could replicate that
that's what I was worried about because
it's like the red I know what color that
is cuz I used to get it at Sally so I
know what color that is um and I really
love that color it's like a warm like
super bright red but um the blue I
wanted to match the blue of the wig yeah
that wig looks good but a lot of the
dyes that I've seen are not that exact
color yeah so I feel like if it's going
if it's too dark it's not going to look
as good yeah you know what I mean so I'm
kind of worried about that
yeah filbert also says I was roofied
once it was not a good thing I was as
well um at this was before I met you mhm
and it was at iar where iar used to be
when it was
downtown and and I was there with my
ex-husband and a friend of ours named
Nicole and I guess like she was she knew
some people there that I didn't know
Nicole I'm thinking of um no you I don't
think you know this girl she hasn't no
not that girl okay um not Cole yeah okay
this was a girl I don't think you've
ever met her she hasn't been out for
years and years I she just contacted me
again the other day and she said oh I
just moved back and what's going on and
stuff like that but I hadn't seen her
for [__] ages so yeah she was there
and she had some people with her but I
didn't know them so I suspect I'm not
accusing anybody but I suspect that one
of them was the one that did it because
they were kind of hanging around and I
didn't know them but it could have been
some random person I don't really know
but the stupid thing was that so I'm
there and I'm like you know where that
um thing was where you know where the
stairs were that used to go up to the
bathroom like on the third floor and
there was that little there was like a
little table there what where were we
talking about that the old Eye bar like
when it was downtown so I was sitting
over there and there was other people
around it wasn't I wasn't sitting there
by myself I had one drink oh yeah yeah
yeah I had one drink and then I drank
maybe half of it and like you know I can
drink you know you know so one drink
like I drank half of it and I was like
you guys I don't feel that good and I
just went and I just [__] passed out
somebody got you they had to carry me
out of the place and then I woke up my
ex-husband was driving me back home and
I was puking in my lap yeah hooray so
fun yeah got you I know why somebody
roofied me because it was very obvious
that I was there with a bunch of other
people I think it's funny I guess or
maybe or maybe the guy that did
it didn't wasn't observant like you're
going to have to be an idiot to do that
to somebody anyway somebody got me yeah
but it
wasn't it was I think I think the person
that did I got I got an idea who it was
it was it was a guy that was after
her I know who it was I asked him if he
did he wouldn't he wouldn't admit to it
good thing he knew better because Le the
legal ramifications could have had his
ass [__] locked up for that and I
don't know what it was I never felt
anything like that yeah you were I just
started losing my mind you did yeah you
were acting like [__] insane I
started to get [__] pissed off at the
music and [__] and uh I was able to
drive I had
coordination but no I drove no you drove
didn't you yeah yeah that's right
because I remember I was just like
screaming at you the whole time like on
the way home cuz I didn't know it was
the matter with you I was just very
disoriented cuz I just thought you were
acting like an ass I was reason but I
don't and I went back to and I dropped
you off at your house and I was like get
out yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I
don't know what it was she didn't really
know me that well when that happened
that was a while back I think that was
even before we weren't dating I don't
think we were even dating at that time
it's just it was a it was a concert and
I was like oh I want to go and I don't
really want to go by myself so I called
you and said hey would you go with me so
you're like yeah sure so so we went and
then like there we had a couple other
people there but yeah there was another
guy who was trying to date Jen who saw
me as an obstacle and he spped me
something we we suspect yeah he spped me
something to try to make me look bad
because I have never seen you act like
that before or since no other than kind
of when you're on Trend but it wasn't
even the same thing not the same thing I
don't know what it was it was just uh
you were you're acting like a total
lunatic
yeah I don't know what it was I don't
know what the drug that was what it was
I've never had it before yeah might have
been ketamine or something I don't know
yeah maybe
it was like an out of- Body
Experience yeah you watch it's like I
was seeing myself do stuff yeah I didn't
know what the [__] you the matter well
because it didn't occur to me that
somebody would have done that because
like I said that's usually something
people do to chicks so it's just kind of
like and it happened on the first drink
yeah maybe second
yeah yeah I think we only had one or two
yeah it felt like some kind of weird
panic attack
yeah then I felt like I was under attack
from something and I was trying to fight
back yeah at everything I wanted to
fight everything I don't know what it
was yeah I think it might have been
something like
camine yeah maybe that's what it was but
yeah that was a [__] I still kind of
remember that night too yeah I don't I
didn't feel like it felt like an out of-
body experience I felt like I was
watching myself do this yeah and I don't
really remember what what it was that I
did yelling at the band was one of the
things yeah you were just like screaming
your head off and I was just like you
shut up it's like St yeah yeah trying to
fight everything cuz it was a small
place so wasn't you know it wasn't like
a big venue or anything like that it was
like a small Club I don't know what it
was I can't identify the drug I never
and finally like the show wasn't even
over I'm like we have to go yeah I'm
like I can't have [__] we just got there
we we were only there for like an hour
or so yeah we weren't there for very
long when have I ever done that yeah
like I said I can drink people
underneath the table like I said it
didn't occur to me at the time so I was
just mad at you because I thought you
were being a dick cuz like I said I
didn't really know you didn't really
know me that well I didn't know you that
well at that point so I was just like
what the [__] is the matter with you
it's like I wanted to go to this show I
forgot all about that actually yeah but
so long ago I forgot all about that yeah
it was some but I I drove I drove you
home really I didn't remember that I
couldn't drive and I was just yeah well
I don't know if you couldn't drive but I
was mad and I was like well it was my
car it was your car okay so I was just
kind of like yeah because I dropped you
off at your house cuz I was like was I
making any S I was like get the [__] out
of my car I was really mad at you um
what did I say not really I don't even
remember now cuz this was a long time
ago I mean like I said this was before
we even got together this was probably
like 2010 or 20 yeah I don't know it was
the only time that ever happened early
2011 yeah I've never seen you act like
that it was some kind of drug like I
said even when you were on Trend where
you were acting like a lunatic it wasn't
you were acting like a lunatic but it
wasn't quite the same right the same way
that you were acting like a lunatic yeah
it only lasted for
about half hour
maybe 30 20 30 minutes it started to
kind of calm down I don't know what it
was something weird yeah it was [__]
crazy some kind of exotic drug I don't
know and I didn't feel
uh didn't feel incapacitated or
intoxicated yeah you weren't acting
drunk no it felt you were acting like
aggro like super super angry yeah yeah
you know I mean like yeah for no reason
right like that's what I mean so I was
just so I didn't get it like I'm like
what the [__] is your problem yeah cuz
like I said I didn't know yeah High
Desert said my neighbor got ruied at a
local bar her friends caught her being
carried out of the bar by two strange
guys they didn't
know see that's what happens never leave
your drink unattended yeah nobody should
ever well that's not that could have
been two nice guys trying to get her to
her car I would not make that assumption
you don't
know right but you don't know but but
I'm not willing to risk it I'm just
going remember what happened to
Tori remember what happened to Tori
right what happened what what what what
are we talking about what um incident
are we talking Tory is a a true Indian
princess she's a MAA Indian and she's a
punk
rocker big beautiful blue hair I just
saw a picture she posted today she does
have beautiful multicolored hair yeah
beautiful blue hair and um it's kind of
rainbow or I think it's magenta now
actually she um her dad is like part of
like he works at Washington DC he's part
of the Indian what is it called Indian
something or other thing it's Bureau of
Indian Affairs he works for that and
um she's a a punk rock Andy and Princess
her dad's a chief and [__] she's cool I
like her yeah I had to pull up a picture
of her anyway uh she was at this is
during that time of
iar everybody getting roofi there was
kind of a few months there where a lot
of people yeah there was like a two or
three month period right there where all
these girls were somebody was knocking
them out with something in that club and
that might have been the the same time
period when I got yeah yeah it was I
remember it was and that was almost the
same time period that that [__] happened
to me that was a little bit that was
later because I think when it happened
to me I think that was either before I
met you okay or when we didn't really
know each other that well like I
probably because I'd been seeing you for
a long time so was within about a year
yeah it was in yeah it was right around
like 2009 is 2010 somewhere around there
right well um Tori and her boyfriend
showed up and they were having a good
time they were only there for about an
hour and a half and then remember that
out of the
blue me and her boyfriend are dragging
her out of the CL dragging her out
remember and she's just falling down
saying I'm sorry I'm sorry oh I do
remember that and we're like what's
happening I don't know and she's just
going I had forgotten all about that and
we say okay well we're get her into a
car somebody must have slipped or
something and she just keeps falling
down saying I'm sorry I'm
sorry yeah that's see that's [__] up
see when it happened to me like I said
it was I had had like literally half a
drink yeah and like I said I can drink a
lot before I'm falling down okay so it's
like I had had like half a drink and I
just went
unconscious all I remember was telling
my ex-husband and my friend hey I don't
feel all that good and then I just fell
off the stool and I don't remember
anything until I woke up in the car on
the drive home throwing up in my lap I
remember nothing so I'm guessing they
had to drag me out
but I don't remember any of
that so yay so I can imagine had I been
there by myself because later on after
me and my ex-husband broke up I did go
there by myself a lot of times although
I generally had a lot of friends there
like that I met up with so I wouldn't
have been alone but you know people
would watch out for me but you know what
I mean that's princess Tori right there
and that's about what she looked like
that's a good picture of her
yeah she always takes a good pictures
she's very she's very photogenic yeah
like I said even the one I she posted
one today that was really nice too yeah
so when you think of Indian princess
don't be stereotypical that
she see I like that hair color I want
something a little lighter than that
though slightly yeah you know what I
mean but that's kind of the color that
I'm kind of going
for but Tori was a maaw they were kind
of up there near Washington State well
still is yeah yeah you know it's just
sorry I'm being
I'm being a grammar yeah the
gramar she's a MAA and they're from uh
Washington State up on the coast they're
almost kind of like Inuit they're
they're whale hunting
Indians they're some of the last people
in the in the United States I think
they're the last people who can legally
hunt whale they're they're able to do it
on a certain
Festival yeah Philbert said afterwards I
just didn't realize why the bouncer
didn't realize what something was wrong
with me they propped me in a corner
before carrying me out I mean you would
think that more people would know like
what was going on nowadays but I don't
know maybe if if people aren't really
watching how much you drank they're like
ah they're just like super drunk you
know what I mean
but I don't know that was that was the
most one of the most [__] up things
that ever happened to me and like I said
I don't remember that's for real I think
I'm far as I know that's the only time
that it's happened to me I don't
remember it ever happening to me
otherwise
um so that's good but there was kind of
a time there in like you said around
2009 2010 and I don't know if it was the
same person doing it the whole time I've
heard rumors about who it was but um I
don't know if I believe them or
not but there were a lot of people that
got ruied right around the at iar right
around the time say she looks like an
anime character she does kind of yeah F
says she beautiful she is beautiful
Sammy says she gives off Cindy laugher
Vibes yeah yeah she's super sweet too
yeah I haven't seen her in a while girl
could dance that girl dance yeah she's
like it's funny because she's more she's
like a death metal girl yeah she [__]
loves death metal every time I saw her
she had a death metal vanand t-shirt on
yeah she was uh she dated the vegan
black metal Chef for while that's right
I forgot they had a thing going for a
little
while yeah lik death metal but she likes
goth stuff too she go she goes goth
events we just saw vegan black metal
Chef um last time yeah last time we went
to momento he was at momento last time
couple weeks ago yeah yeah we see him
all he usually comes out so we see him a
lot um Zach says if you guys come to the
gay bar I like to go to during pride
month y'all will think you're rued
places like walking into a Lynch movie
oh that sounds fun though I'm all about
that
action dy's talking about going to the
glory hole what's this D you going to
the glory hole oh boy [__] what' he say
[Laughter]
wait a minute where where am I bottom oh
uh have you ever seen a glory hole in
the men's room of a gay bar or is that
unheard of just wondering because I've
seen a glory hole in Bloom's Fairgrounds
men's
bathroom we were talking the other day
about about doing a glory hole video
yeah because we were just kind of like
how funny would it be if we cuz the park
that we film at sometimes sounds like
wouldn't it be funny if we did like a
glory hole video and it's like I like
you'll pretend yeah where's this like oh
my God a random dick and then like you
know what I mean oh my God that would be
so funny I'll put the camera up on a
[__] trap Bo we should totally do
that that would be hilarious was like I
was thinking about I was thinking about
doing some [__] like going do shooting
some outdoor [__] yesterday but of
course it [__] rained all day you
know yeah and then today I had a bunch
of other [__] to do and it was cold so I
mean it's not cold cold but I mean you
went out in it it was it today yeah but
it was cold as a it was cold as [__] I
mean for a Floridian it was pretty well
also for a motorcycle cuz wind chill
[__] lowers the temperature down to
nothing he had to put the liner in his
Jack yeah I'm glad I had it on I was
still [__] cold my [__] teeth were
[__]
chattering yeah cuz I told you when you
left I was like it's only like 54
degrees yeah and when you're going
[__] 70 or 80 it feels like [__]
30 you're
[Music]
like and you know we're Floridians so
we're used to heat and [__] humidity
I'm actually comfortable at 80 and 90°
now I don't like it in the house
absolutely but outside I don't have a
problem with it it's weird because I was
born in Florida and here's the funny
thing this is and this is absolutely
true people that were born in Florida
except for me um it's it gets down to 65
degrees you will legitimately see
Floridians walking around with [__]
parkas on yeah it's ridiculous um I
don't do that like it I don't even wear
I'll wear a hoodie if it gets down into
the 50s maybe if it gets down to the 40s
I might wear a hoodie but I don't have
that I'm not wearing a [__] Parker
I'll be like burning up so I was born in
Florida but I kind of like cold weather
you know what I mean I don't I don't I
don't think 65 is cold I don't think 55
is cold you know what I mean like I said
says looks what he says it look like a
90s what or 2000 [__] WWE wrestler
early
2000 you do kind of yeah I was at the
[__] this is a while back now I guess
it's been about 3 four months I went up
to [__] in uh the Oasis the [__]
little biker bar of a [__] road I go
to I was about half lit and the dude
says what are you some kind of wrestler
and I thought he was [__] with me I
was almost going to whip his ass up
behind it so what what are you talking
about you look like a wrestler and I
says what you f trying he's like no no
no I just thought you were a wrestler
said man [__] talk to
me don't be so cranky Tom I know I
thought he was making fun of me were you
on Trend no drop thought I guess I did
look like a wrestler but I don't IM
imagine myself looking like that you
know you should have just gone like are
you ready to rumble you should have done
that that have been super funny yeah
just got to roll with it it's fun I
thought he was [__] [__] with me
no don't be like that yeah don't be like
that cuz I I forgot I forgot how I
looked I forgot what I looked like for
for
like I thought he was [__] I thought
he was talking about my [__] boots oh
you know what I'm talking about cuz
those do and I was like make the [__]
out of
here cuz I was wearing I was wearing
[__] still crabby huh I was on guard
actually I was still on Shen well that's
what I just asked you and you said no
yeah I was oh okay that was on Tren well
that explains it then yeah cuz you were
super cranky when you yeah it didn't
make any sense on Trend what are you
talking about yeah shut up don't look at
me yeah I see a dude [__] off see a
dud in the car next to me laughing and I
think he's laughing at me who you
[__] looking no not like get ready
bro I'm listening to some funny getting
ready jump out a car [__] beat on
Spotify chill the [__] out you get you
get over overly [__] Godlike ego and
you're at one hand and and then you're
insecure as [__] you think everybody's
making fun of
you you're like pregnant Superman I'm
telling you man it's [__] weird you
ever do that again I ain't doing any
train anymore and
look I don't I don't know if [__] uh
bu Zack is still listening we were
talking about HRT the other
day test a [__] love testosterone I
like all the steroids they're all good
most most civilians don't really know
what they like I've tried them all
basically but there's one you just don't
want to do
it's it's just that stereotypical you
know oh he's got Roid Rage I've never
experienced any of that [__] except with
Trent and you don't think you're mad you
love it but you're [__] angry you're
trying to stop everybody else is like
what the [__] is the matter with you but
you're like nothing's the matter with me
I'm God that's why yeah yeah yeah I will
kill you and I'm just kind of like
you're just looking cool cool yeah yeah
you don't I'm going to be over here with
all the doors locked and some knives
I've done a lot I've done all the
[__] major drugs and everything and
um as far as hormones go which steroids
are just synthetic
hormones um TR was up there with LSD in
terms of mind bending it's a mind alter
altering [__] experience LSD is fun
though lsd's fun very positive this is a
[__] you're a const with Tren you're
at a constant war with the dark
side it's just like off of [__] that
Spider-Man movie where Oswald [__]
became the Green Goblin because he took
the [__] high performance [__]
combat steroids and [__] he's now
divided into two a real simpy half and a
[__] evil half that is trying to take
over it's just like that whoever wrote
that [__] took Tren they know all about
it they're probably yeah I'm G write
story based around this nonsense that's
because tren's been around for a long
time it's just a it's just an Esther of
nerone and uh it was not approved for
human use it's [__] very effective
very
inexpensive lot of bang for the buck but
if you're on that thing longer than
[__] 90 days you're going to go crazy
you're going to love it you're going to
want to take every single person in your
life is going to be like yeah I'm just
back away
slowly and what's weird about you have
fun with that is that you're loving it
in a certain sense that the evil is
taking over mhm and uh you don't want to
come off you're like what do you mean n
days that ain't [__] I'm going to live
on
this and it's just like Dr Jackal Mr
Hyde stories
or Oswald and the Goblin and or Venom
where you got an evil thing that's
making you stronger like in the Star
Wars prequels if they had had Anakin
Skywalker take Tren and then that's what
turned him into Darth Vader it would
have been a lot more believable yeah I'm
just saying you're you're in in a war
with the dark side is at in a war with
you that's what it is you know what I
mean it's telling you how weak you are
and how good it is just do what you want
to do it's just you know yeah he just
wanted to kill everybody and beat
everyone's ass you really need to cut
people's heads off yeah it's like it's
that kind of [__] yeah so please don't
take it no it's not it's not um a pre
for human use no it was veter take it
yeah but and here's the [__] thing
these Jim Bros take it they get results
off of it but some of them do crazy [__]
and I'm getting killed by the cops
that yep that's happened it's a
relationship killer yep all right yeah
their wives and girlfriends I'm out
because they don't have any idea what
they're getting it into all right and
and here's the thing it's not any more
really stronger than just regular
nandrolone like Deca or NPP it's about
like that it's just that it has such
terrible side effects people associate
that with strength like oh it must be
very powerful in terms of like muscle
building and everything no it's about
like the other ones it's just it has
terrible side effects yeah so there's
really no reason take over the other
ones right and it is cheaper so you can
take more of it okay well that's the
only thing it's about half the price is
a half a price for the reason yeah okay
because you shouldn't take it don't take
it like I
said now they'll have these graphs where
they're like well it's five times more
anabolic and five times more androgenic
than than than an equal amount of
[__] testosterone I don't really
believe
those charts yeah it might feel like
five times or it might pass certain
chemical tests that it's five times more
powerful but you won't gain five times
the the amount of muscle it's going to
be about the same that what it yields so
no don't do it do Deca testosterone Deca
or NPP those are the best ones don't
[__] with dball it's not worth
it anavar is not worth it for a man half
of the women don't really respond to
anavar are I didn't she didn't yeah I
mean some people do but I didn't she
responded to 19 North testosterone that
was the only thing cuz he's he gave me
all kind of stuff and like nothing
happened but when he first started
giving me that like that actually DEA
she immediately responded to it yeah I
started losing a bunch of weight and
like you know had body recomposition and
like my legs started looking different
and all this other kind of stuff yeah
got very sexy very quickly and on a very
small amount of it but that was the only
one that did that like all the previous
ones hadn't done anything right except
maybe Mickey deepen your voice
wind did do that it roughened your voice
it did yeah but a lot of that's
temporary I'm not like I'm not that
bothered by it I'm not really that
bothered by it or it'll fade over time
and the thing about it is that it didn't
really occur to me like I said
until um a friend of ours like mentioned
it because it said hey I was watching
some of your old videos and it's like
you had like a much higher voice like
back in the old days like I didn't
really notice it yeah cuz it happened
kind of slowly um but I don't know it
doesn't really bother me Jen was not
highly uh was not a highly uh hormonal
woman to begin with um well I've never
been super fi either she wasn't real Fe
yeah and there's certain details about
Jen that [__] only the boyfriend
would know about okay [__] oh my God
what are we talking about we Shen
[__] blossomed in some [__] very
nice ways uh [__] oh I think I know
yeah a lot of things changed very
rapidly um for for for the better
um Jens leido [__] kicked up her her
but that's typical really of Androgen
use for for female and I had a fairly
High one to start with yeah and it got
higher yeah yeah but that's okay that's
a good thing it's good for old people
yeah because we're going to have fun
before we go and we're going to be
strong and be healthy the whole second
half
yeah you know yeah that's all right
filbert says I did LSD once it was
amazing yeah yeah Tom's done Tom's done
it a bunch of times um so and I was like
well I want to do it so he's like okay
we'll get some so we got some from a
friend of ours I'm not saying whose name
is and um man that was a great [__]
experience yeah I'm glad you were there
because I wanted to do all kind of crazy
[__] and you're like yeah let's not do
that but um you know what I mean don't
go outside and roll around in the grass
or anything like that like people might
see you but um honestly like I had and I
know that some people have said oh they
have a bad trip or whatever I did not I
had a super super positive experience
and I would do it again in a heartbeat
it was super fun all right there's guys
talking to me uh okay yeah uh Zach bu
act here he said he's thinking about
going to like a professional right
that's where I started with hormone
replacement I went to a uh a clinic so I
had a doctor they did the blood tests
and everything and uh here it's very
wide open they'll they'll find an excuse
to give you testosterone and if you pay
extra they'll give you a nandrolone
they'll [__] give you [__]
sarms uh growth hormones they'll they'll
give you anything if you're willing to
pay for it I
mean in this state and probably in all
states doctors are really kind of
glorified drug dealers if you have the
money they'll sell it to you they
getting commissions on all this
[__] so if you're more comfortable with
HRT I I I would really if you want to
you can start in a clinic they're
expensive they're about 200 bucks a
month on the gray Market you can get
better test stronger for half that or
one quarter of that from other countri
from other ways okay but one thing that
a clinic can give you can do for you is
it gives you peace of mind you will know
what 200 mgram of DEC decent quality
testosterone feels like a weak and using
that
Baseline you'll know whether or not
you're getting good or bad [__] later
see I think that's why I think I think
it's good that you went like the
legitimate route yeah I went the
legitimate route first the first you
know and they and they you went back
there like every month or something and
they you know checked your blood and
they checked all your levels and
everything like that so they kept an eye
on you they keep an so when you go to
the clinic an HRT Clinic they're really
teaching you how to a responsible user
yeah that's really what they're doing
and they probably know that I'm sure
they probably know that and then after
about a year once I was going online and
was getting recommendations from other
guys who take it saying look man this is
an even better source and I'll I got the
websites all right it's an international
dealer that [__] represents about
five or six really good Laboratories
that are in other countries countries
where the shit's sold over the counter
and they can give you all kind get you
all kind kinds of stuff they're going to
take a commission but still for under
for about a hundred bucks if if it's
just a month you can for about a 100
bucks you can get two months worth of
[__]
test
okay so it's half the price and then you
want to th once you get done once you
start [__] with test there's other
stuff like Deca you might want to mess
with that's even better okay and you
start you're you're you're it's just
like these girls and these titties okay
if you're going to go get some implants
those girls are going to be dedicated to
implants the rest of their life they're
not going to want the implants gone
they're going to want them big old
titties and next time they get another
set of titties it's going to be bigger
set of
titties hormone replacement and steroids
are kind of like that you're going to go
oh I'm not coming off a test this shit's
doing too much for me I'm growing
younger I feel better you know what I
mean I'm actually [__] I feel like I
do when I'm younger and I'm actually the
numbers are there to prove it I'm I'm
looking at what I'm [__] lifting I'm
looking in the mirror I'm looking at the
sex life that I have now so this is this
is the way I'm going to go you're in a
much better mood much better mood I
noticed that like as soon as you started
going to the um trt Clinic yeah um your
mood like improved immediately
immediately immediately you're like oh I
forgot what this was because before that
you seemed like you were kind of like
bummed out bummed out like a [__]
somebody says as you get older you
become more like the villains yeah you
become
cold you become in a weird way coold you
just seemed like you were always like
kind of tired and you were like whatever
you were always kind of like that in his
late he's in his late knowing what I
know now I would have gone on in my late
30s yeah he says that a lot he didn't
really go on until late 40s yeah late
40s I would have gone on in my late 30s
knowing what I CU there's a lot of [__]
that happened in my late 30s and my 40s
I didn't realize it was because of the
effects of low test yeah your body just
doesn't make as much as it used to it's
part of the natural age ing process
which is what dying you're dying you're
slowly shutting down okay I mean that's
sure but like don't think of it that way
that's what it is I know I know that's
what it is you keep bumping keeping it
for a man it's almost like the the
Fountain of Youth just keep the
testosterone levels High the longer
you're on it kind of like the higher you
like it to be but there's a kind of like
an overdose point of testosterone so
what you can do is you can lower the
test level and [__] replace it with a
synthetic modified testosterone that has
a higher overdose point and less side
effects that's steroids steroids are
testosterone but it's testosterone you
can give to a woman or a child to heal
them up if they get burned or damaged
you can use that as a testosterone
replacement you you must have
testosterone for basic function it's
called a
Bas but instead of running High test
levels which has a lot of side effects
you can cut some of the test levels down
and replace it with
steroids as long as you have some test
in there you're good and and we're
scientists in it we know the ratios some
of them want 2:1 ratio some of them 3 to
one some of half and half and each one
of those little steroids you can only
run it for a certain amount of time and
then you're going to be the side effects
start like you don't feel that good so
you want to CH change to another one
you're constantly
rotating
which steroid you're using every five
months maybe but it's okay you know
there's a lot of them and you can bounce
around between them or you can just run
straight
test just that you kind of get a
resistance to test but it still gives
you good
results
um so you're you're going to be like a
girl with implants you're going to be
dealing with
implants well is you're a guy now you're
going to be you're dealing with
testosterone and steroids you're going
to be dealing with that if you stop
dealing with it the aging process takes
back over in in the way that it does you
kind of start to slowly revert back to
Old Man status so you have to stay on
top of
it but it can extend life yeah you know
well you know people think well it must
be bad for you no no [__] Jack Lane
lived in 97 or 96 and he was on test in
anavar and he was healthy his whole life
long as you don't abuse it you can yeah
you just like I said everything and you
know you got to know what you're doing
you know what I mean don't just you have
to know what you're doing you have to
understand your body and how things feel
because you you're
replacing your endri
system with a
synthetic version of this of the of the
endri system and it's it's uh it's
coming from outside your body you're not
making these hormones you're injecting
them so you have to know you have to
make sure you have the money for this
which really not that much under 200 a
month and uh that you got the
sources so you might want a stockpile of
it like well [__] man I may not be able
to get this for you know another four
months I think I'm buy four bottles you
know that kind of
[__] Tammy says that one wrestler killed
his wife and himself all on Tren yeah
that's right yeah but that wasn't Trend
it wasn't a trend that did that that was
those multiple head injuries he had well
I'm sure that didn't help his brain was
one big [__]
bruise I mean his job was to take blows
to the Head they were just he was just
is getting hit and head over and over
again with [__] metal
shares so it wasn't just a trend
anything like that anything where like
wrestling or football or anything like
that where you're just constantly
getting hit in the head um those people
are going to yeah um yeah th those
people are going to have problems later
on you can't keep doing that to your
brain and expect to act normal this is
what I didn't like about that situation
they they erased that
guy's history from from the WWF is that
was it I think it was WWF not e and then
they got they got rid of that guy's
[__] action figure and everything
they pretended like that guy never
existed I mean I can see why they did
that they want to sell that was terrible
I know but they should have said that
look this guy
was a a casualty of the sport yeah well
it would be good if everybody kind of
talked about that yeah cuz that wasn't
him that did that he was out of his mind
yeah he was he was not in his right mind
he' been Bea in the head over and over
again I saw videos that that he was
getting head getting hit in the head
with metal chairs several times a week
over and over again although on the
other side of that I could see how if
you were you know the family of his wife
they'd be like yeah we don't really give
a [__] about it he still killed her like
she's still dead so yeah yeah but he was
it's just like that guy up there in
[__] in the in the clock tower that
shot all those people up he shot all
those people but he had a brain t in his
size but all those people are still dead
like so he was dead too sure he was
dying too and he he was not in his right
mind he was malfunctioning yeah so it
was almost well like natural disaster
yeah and I think we talked about that on
our when we did a show about Charles
whitmann um it's almost like more like a
natural disaster like a natural disaster
he he was a victim also he didn't he
didn't choose to do that [__] he he
could not make a decision he was he had
a brain tumor in in his [__] brain as
size of a [__] softball if I remember
correctly it was big yeah it was very
big he wasn't he wasn't in charge it was
just like a natural
disaster so he didn't have sad he didn't
have more he didn't have moral
responsibility he was insane yeah well
that was the same about that wrestler
guy he was
insane well here's one of the things
about steroids good thing about steroids
if you have a head injury your brain
starts swelling you you pump that dude
filled with steroids what they did to me
me after my motorcycle wrecked that
first Thomas had a head injury also if
you are new here and what steroids do um
if you have a head injuries that stops
the swelling of your
brain and it can which prevents a lot of
damage a lot of brain damage then you'll
have a instead of a [__] massive
[__] head injury you kind of just
have effectively a concussion you you
you can repair that damage will be
better well that wrestler was constantly
cranking up on [__]
steroids so he's getting hit in the head
with that [__] chair on a regular
basis and he doesn't understand how much
damage he's taking you know what I mean
he thinks he might have a very mild
concussion no you had a serious
concussion many of them and they just
added up over times and he was having
fun he he loved his trade he was a he
was he's evidently by all accounts he
was a great
guy but you're just not built to take
that kind of brain Dam damage over and
over and over again you're going to [__]
up it's your brain it's your brain right
let's not [__] with the brain too much
right but he loved his job he's trying
to put on a great show and he his
friends just beating the [__] out of him
with [__] chairs and [__] but he's
taking multiple head injuries every time
he does a show that's how dedicated he
was and he's on [__] stage he doesn't
realize it he doesn't really feel it
right uh the brain isn't swelling he's
not it's not knocking him out he's not
ending up in the hospital but he should
have been
well yeah so he thinks oh it's fine he
thinks it's fine no you had a massive
head trauma and you need realize it yep
so um there's some preventative mainten
there's some preventative it's actually
kind of protective to have steroids in
your
system um you can take a head injury and
not suffer the total consequences of it
that doesn't mean go out and take
multiple
ones [__] and that's what he was doing
yeah he was he was just trying to make a
bunch of money and put on a good show he
was having fun I mean that was his job
that was his job right and you know and
if it wasn't having an effect like you
know like he thought maybe it should
have he's like oh it's fine like yeah
it's fine yeah he hit me with he hit me
with that [__] but it didn't it didn't
hurt me right yeah it did yep you had
you took a [__] serious [__]
concussions many of them a night and
like I said that's your brain that's
your brain yeah that's kind of your
whole uh that's kind of your whole [__]
there right so I feel bad for his family
and everything that happened I feel bad
for him too he was a victim he he did
not choose to do that he wasn't in his
right mind he wasn't rational he was
insane but I kind of think that the
[__]
WWF were pieces of [__] for turning
their back on the on one of their
own who was a casualty I mean they could
have used that as like kind of a they
could have used way to talk about yeah
about head injuries and [__] how much
they're sacrificing for the sport and
that there could have been a way they
could have played that out where they
didn't have to turn their back on their
own they could have honored everybody
cuz I kind of feel like they did that
more like in the NFL because you know
they kind of started talking about like
all the pet injuries and stuff that
those people were same thing NFL NFL
kind of owned up to it that's what I
mean so they kind of used that but and I
kind of feel like that's what the
wrestling Community should have done and
they uh the wrestling Community could
have said we're going to have new rules
you can't hit people in the head with
objects you can't do this you know what
I mean cuz even if you pull your punches
you can you're still hitting the person
in the head they're going to have to
have some kind of standards of what that
thing weighs how hard you're hitting
somebody they can make it off limits to
hit anybody in the
head yeah so there had to be more
controls that way at least you're not
fake he was really getting hit in the
head with a [__] chair yeah I mean
you look at today's wrestling man that's
weak sauce compared to when I was a kid
it looked [__] real violent cuz it
was it was real like I said they did did
kind of pull back a little bit but they
still wanted it to look realistic yeah
some of it was yeah they really were
cutting themselves sometimes you see
blood [__] but they they they they
had [__] bits of [__] razor blade
hit on hidden on them and they'd make a
real fine cut after they got hit to make
it look like the hit it was fake but it
was real blood they stopped doing all
that with AIDS epidemic that's part of
it probably a good idea and uh let's not
get Biohazard over everything those
those old school wrestlers are really
committed and put to putting on a good
show yeah and uh they were like Macho
yeah hit me hit me hit me for real uh
now they weren't trying to they were
they were like rodeo clowns as being a
good uh that was like a good originally
like that would be a good way to
describe them they got hurt for real but
they were trying to pull punches it was
all an act in a
way but it was
violent yeah you know like stunt man you
know
sure filbert says uh Happy New Year
everyone I have to leave but we'll be
back next week for sure get drunk have
fun and stay safe who was that you guys
rock filbert yeah thank you Happy New
Year you have fun too everybody stay
safe this weekend please you know what I
mean just
saying yeah Sebastian said Chris was one
of my favorite wrestlers yeah it's you
know that was we watched that
documentary about that happening and it
was just kind of a sad [__] case all
around sad case all around
oh so yeah so filbert let us know how
the hair turns out because I want to see
it too I want to see it too let me see I
think I missed like a whole bunch of
stuff yeah they're talking about bath
salts I remember that like that dude
that ate that other dude's face which of
course was in Florida but I think they
determined that that wasn't even bath
salts I don't even know what they
figured that I don't even know if that
was drugs I think that dude was just
[__] crazy you know what I
mean um BT said tried shrooms didn't
feel much yeah it's just
I've never done DMT or anything like
that but I don't know I had a really
positive experience on LSD and I'm kind
of looking forward to doing it again I
liked it a lot liked it a
lot um one of the best I'm not a big fan
of weed like the few times that I've
smoked weed I just like didn't really
like it it just made me super paranoid
and I'm like yeah I don't need that [__]
but most of but LSD was the only drug
that was like oh yeah I could see myself
doing this again this is super fun but
in a way that it's just kind of you
don't want to do it all the time but
it's like a special occasion kind of
it's like yeah let's let's like you know
just kind of snack like stockpile some
snacks and stuff like that and just stay
in the house this weekend and then we'll
do some LSD and then we'll do some [__]
around the house you know what I mean
it's that kind of thing you got to plan
ahead because it's kind of special you
know what I
mean um Oscar is trying to get you to
take Tren
again oh that's really good but that's
that's that flavored vodka oh is it yeah
it's good oh it smells
good oh man that is good that's the
first uh like I said we got some people
know us so well yeah we got some uh
flavored vodka for Christmas and it's
pineapple and mango I'm not hu usually a
huge fan of mango but that's actually
quite nice and it's more pineapple
forward and it's got really nice like
mixed with the fruit punch there
very very
nice yeah Zach's talking about the
documentary yeah we watched that too
it's like I said it's just kind of sad
and I know
that I don't even remember did we do a
show about it I don't remember if we did
a show about it or if we just like
talked about it because we watched the
documentary but um it's just kind of
like a sad case all around
because I feel like if all that [__] had
happened to him he wouldn't have done
that but I'm sure that probably doesn't
make her family feel any better
so but like Tom said it's kind of like
when we talked about [__] Charles
Whitman the guy that killed all his
people from the you know the clock tower
on the campus and he had a big [__]
brain tumor and that's why he did it
what's that so you know what you talking
about nothing I got a I got a um pee too
so but they're talking about
shrooms so get in on that shrooms while
I get to the bathroom
I don't think I've ever actually taken
shrooms I don't think I have either now
that I'm thinking about it I remember
seeing them and friends used to take
them
okay back it up see if I missed
anything
okay bath salts remember I don't know
what bath salts
were I remember when that guy over here
in Florida ate that one bum ate the
other bum's
face they got it partially on camera
where they got naked and went down in
between the dividing line between the
two freeways and one bomb ate the other
bomb's
face
uh they said it was bath salts that did
that but they never really just never
really explained what bath salts were
see I thought it wasn't bath salts I
thought yeah they came out later said it
wasn't bath salts that's what I thought
I don't remember if there were actually
any drugs in that dude's system or if so
what they were yeah but I thought that
they determined and I could be totally
wrong about this that drugs were not the
cause of it maybe he was just a crazy
person or a
zombie perhaps it's a weird flavor
though is it it's not weird yeah okay I
didn't think it was weird I thought it
was
delicious Now take me a second to adapt
to that it's a mango flavor or no it's
mango and pineapple mango and pineapple
yeah like I said it's not I don't really
taste much mango it tastes more
pineapple to me pineapple it's what it
is but you know what
me um let's see yeah and Jus for me said
I believe
uh quarterback uh yeah Brett F stated
his memory is [__] since quitting
football that doesn't surprise me others
are even coming down with ALS yeah
didn't your stepdad have that ALS no it
was L Garrick's disease oh you sure is
isn't it yeah L Garrick's disease I
thought that was two different
things Hugo said my birthday was
yesterday happy birthday happy yeah I
thought it was ALS um happy late
birthday some friends invited me to see
mly crew this weekend in home Springs
how much do they weigh now how much do
they weigh now what collectively yeah
yeah I haven't seen them in a long time
I wasn't like a big mle crew fan but
yeah Tammy said I remember not believing
it when it came out about the dude
eating the other dude's face no he ate
the dude's face like no way it was a
true story um this is Florida we believe
[Laughter]
everything it's like we see the [__] and
we're like yeah that sounds like some
[__] that would have happened out here
dude eating a dude's face yep weren't
they naked too yeah they were naked
having sex or something and then they
started one dude started eating the
other dude's
face they were having they were having
bum sex as one does yeah bum sex yeah
don't Google that because there's like a
probably a whole sub genre of porn yeah
of bum sex Zach says he thought your
deeper voice does is good I saw that I
think I think so too yeah it's kind of
like I said it doesn't really bother me
but she just got smoke your voice kind
of like Kim KS or something yeah I got
Betty Davis that yeah but yeah she did
that song right so I could be like
pulling that out of my ass I don't
remember yeah but um I mean I have had
several
people several people ask if I was trans
yeah which I thought was kind of fun I
think they're reflecting with you based
on the fact that maybe we were talking
about that before I think it's snowball
yeah I probably did like I said I'm not
offended I just thought it was kind of
weird she's not trans we got it on
video I got a video of me hitting it
[__] and everything so you see you
see that [__] on Mini pids let go 13 cam
spell it out with in t h i r t n 13 cam
on Min that's our [__] we got to do some
more videos though we're going to do
more yeah last two were okay it just I
didn't love them but I put them up the
lighting was a little weird and just it
was kind of our first times we were
doing like outdoor stuff outdoor stuff
yeah and it was so we weren't real I'm
not sure the outfits were actually that
good for outdoors we'll see the lighting
we were just totally doing [__] on the
Fly making [__] up I'm driving and Jen's
in the seat next to me [__] getting
busy the [__] car is driving by she's
laughing they didn't see either I don't
think so no I don't think they saw I
mean even if they did what are they
going to do yeah they're not going to
stop the car in the oncoming Lane and
[__] yeah it's all right
[Laughter]
yeah Zach said hey Jenny could still be
trans and just had a really good surgeon
yeah that's true I'm not though but like
I said I'm not offended that people say
that it's just I she's all woman I just
thought it was funny that people start
but I think it mostly I guess it's
mostly just because of my voice is it I
don't know I never used to get that
before voice
probably voice in the wigs yeah maybe
that's what it is and and the drawn on
eyebrows
yeah although I just did that because
show them [__] titties man although I
just did that because I'm lazy and I
don't want to pluck my eyebrows so I
just shave them off and then draw them
back on cuz plucking my eyebrows was I
you don't pluck you pluck chickens you
Twee yes yes whatever [__] same thing
it's still plucking no T TW but yeah so
I just got tired of doing it I grew them
back for a little while cuz I was like
I'll have real eyebrows and then I was
like oh man these are a pain in the ass
[__] this and then I shaved them back
off it's much easier to just draw them M
with a [__] pencil you know what I
mean it is I mean I think I don't like
[__] having to tweeze them I usually
would have him do it murder Hornet says
he's going to the Millie vanil concert
tomorrow yeah sure Milly V those dudes
are dead are they or one of them is I
think yeah I think one of them might be
dead
yeah weren't they just they were just
models right yeah they were they were
models and Dancers just lips
syncing yeah that was a whole thing just
some music that some fat dudes were
singing Do you remember like what a big
deal that was back in the 80s it's so
funny to think about now yeah it's funny
to think 0s or 90s I remember funny to
think that people thought that bands
like that were
real as if they came up out of the
nightclub scene you know they rose up
out of the quagar no they were corporate
constructs totally
fake I mean I didn't really care one way
or the other because I didn't like
Millie V so [__] man I was listening to
Bow house and Alien Sex Fiend around
that time man the girls are going crazy
over that [__]
well I didn't I wasn't and I didn't know
anybody that was cuz I didn't hang out
with those people was in high school
yeah [__] Normie chicks were into
that [__] I didn't know any Normie
people I just hung out with
weirdos I had no interest in what the
normies were doing I still don't I still
don't they were wearing them [__]
little short pants and [__] they look
like little F they look like little
[__]
um they look like little black
pilgrims they did kind of they're
Pilgrim outs mention from what I
remember
like I knew dreadlocks because we always
kind of had MTV going in the background
so it's like you know a lot of times so
I'm kind of aware of all that music from
that time period but it's like I wasn't
into it like I wasn't I wasn't you know
they almost look like twins they were
good-looking guys but I could I could
tell something was up with that that
that [__] was too artificial you know
and it was they were lipsyncing that
wasn't them but the thing about it
though is that the voices didn't quite
match the way they looked yeah around
that time period though there were a lot
of kind of like that was kind of the um
maybe it was a little bit before of like
the whole boy band Resurgence where you
had like New Kids on the Block and all
that kind of stuff where it's like none
of them played instruments or nothing
like that they just like danced and sang
you know yeah yeah yeah so everyone was
like okay fair enough but then it wasn't
even them singing so I'm like that's
some [__] it looked wrong to me when
I first saw it I was like that laughing
at Allison going girl you know it girl
you know it like the [__] record was
skipping well the thing that the thing
that blew my mind was that I'm like
they're doing a live show and this was
whenever it was in the '90s or whatever
in the early '90s and I'm like they are
for real using a record like they don't
have like some [__] no cool like tape
or some [__] like that record it was a
record record well record didn't they
think that that would happen record
sounded a lot better than even CD back
in those days I remember [__] when CD
was was new and just coming out and the
guys that bought those CDs players they
have them on pretty expensive stereos
they were talking about how awesome CD
was it was quiet in between songs you
didn't hear any hiss or anything no
scratches at all it was quiet but I
could tell that it didn't quite sound as
good um CU it's compressed that's why
yeah it was it did not sound
resonant and like you could hear the
difference from say like pink flu Dark
Side of the Moon album on CD and [__]
really good quality record and it
sounded better on record it sounded like
they were there playing yeah like they
were there playing and the stereo was a
lot better and uh sometimes you'd have
resident frequencies hitting each other
between two different in instruments
that you could only hear on record you
couldn't hear it on tape either you
could hear it on record a good example
is a fir the The Sisters of Mercy album
first and last and always on record from
1985 from 1985 was [__] outstanding
man [__] it sounds great you listen
to it in modern CD or something off
[__] YouTube it doesn't sound as good
it still sounds good it's still a good
album but it's not it sounded so much
better on record because it was it was
everything did it was engineered for
that and it if you're young and you you
like that band because I know Oscar
likes Sisters of Mercy you got to hear
it on record that preferably on
headphones yeah with headphones and the
the way it was ined engineered it was it
was engineered to be heard that way and
it just sounds a lot
better it's a lot more
organic [__] man I remember prer I
remember listening
to Joy divisions closer on vinyl that
album
sounds enormous yeah it sounds like they
had a bigger scope yeah everything's a
lot richer it's so like immersive yeah
it's like you're in it yeah it's crazy
there is a difference CD never really
had that sound even back not really like
it's still it still sounds cool and
stuff like that but it's not quite the
same well when they bands started to
make music that was developed for to
sound good on CD they engineered the
album right right right you can
re-engineer a a record to CD and and
have okay results but you'll never quite
match that analog sound of of
record well a good Needle on the record
remember how having a good needle
mattered oh yeah and Grill needles in my
time yeah yeah that's right people it
was difficult back in the day for you
youngsters you had to buy a certain kind
of need and they were expensive they
were expensive they would go inside the
record yeah had to have amplifiers and
[__] all kinds of [__] well what kind
of amp you running and speakers and [__]
and uh that sounded a lot better cuz it
was analog it wasn't digital we took
that [__] seriously yeah it was real ser
and [__] they were spend
[__] were spending $5,000 on a
stereos back in the early 80s yeah my D
they were [__] loud and the quality
was really good you'd be able to hear
that [__] three [__] like our
neighbor who blows that [__] here it
sound better than that you'd think that
the [__] live bad was in your room
which he's [__] quiet tonight which
is weird because usually he's super loud
on Friday nights and you would think
that he'd be cranking it because it's
New Year's it's New Year's weekend so
you'd think that he'd be out there like
[__] boom boom like shaking to maybe
I don't know what a shame I don't know
but I'm such a dick I don't like loud
people yeah Allison says go vinyl that's
right they're talking about there is a
big difference there is a big
difference I mean some stuff if you're
not like super into it yeah you can just
listen to it on MP3 or whatever but it's
just kind of
like if it's an album that you're really
really into yeah if you get it on vinyl
and like listen to it on headphones it's
a whole different
experience uh Victor shows up yeah
Victor says hey I made it oh and Oracle
is here too all right yeah what's or all
right Victor shows up I'm going to find
out what made Victor gay today cuz it's
different every time he'll think of
something he'll think of something Zach
says um I wish the rediscovery of vinyl
would happen with film I hate the look
of movies shot on digital especially
period movies yeah film yeah I mean you
know I know that there are like some
filmmakers that are still like kind
of you know making [__] on actual film
but it's getting harder and harder
nowadays and it's like and I get it like
digital is like so much easier and [__]
like that so some things look good on
digital well it depends what it is it
like you said if it's a period film it
probably would look better on actual
film yeah you know uh Jeffy Art's here
too all right everybody's showing
up yeah and Jus me said I remember
Millie vanil on stage and the track
malfunction they ran off in panic yeah
they didn't um they didn't know what to
do like I said their career the thing
that blew my mind about that was that it
was a record they just had like a record
player off the side of the stage
and I was like I somehow I thought it
would be higher Tech than that Isabella
Mar says people didn't care if they were
really singing or not media just made
money out of the story and that's true
one of them killed themselves they said
yeah yeah well um they evidently came
back and actually TR went on a in a band
where they actually were singing in it
that's right they tried to kind of come
back yeah it didn't work though it was
the the the spell had been [__]
shattered it was uh and evidentally they
weren't they didn't sound
like their real voices didn't sound like
of course the the studio musicians that
wrote they were completely different
people yeah the studio musicians that
wrote the songs that got famous were a
couple were a couple fat guys yeah I
think they were black too they were just
they were yeah but like the producers
were like yeah you guys don't look good
enough to like be in the videos so we're
going to like hire some other
[__] to like sing over your
[__] yeah it happens more often than you
would think right now particularly back
then the songs as I remember them I
haven't heard them in a long [__]
time they actually the voes S is sound
it good uh I remember being a real Rich
kind of Baritone [__] sound I
remember thinking that that voice that
dude isn't big enough to [__] sound
like that because they were they were
thin black guys although people thought
that about Rick Ashley too and look
turned that's right true she got me on
that Rick's ass Rick Ashley doesn't look
like that [__] voice could come out
Rick Ashley [__] sounds like a
straight up [__] brother okay he
sounds like a big black dude that's a
big old [__] everybody said that when
he first came on the scene they're like
what that can't be real yeah that's
where Rick Roll came little skinny
Ginger that little skinny British Ginger
yeah yeah little ginger does not sound
like it but he does though he does he
sounded black and he sounded American he
did uh but I that is actually his voice
I didn't even know he was British which
is crazy yeah so it does happen like you
know your [__] look doesn't have to
match your voice yeah and another thing
though is that
it's our prejudice really because Rick
Ashley when you hear that voice you
think that's a black guy he's American
okay I'm going picture him he's medium
build medium to heavy build okay kind of
like a Isaac Hayes type something like
that then you see that little skinny
white dude [__] Ginger you go what
the [__] that's where Rick Roll came
from this him because everyone thought
that that was hilarious yeah right
people were saying that at the time in
87 or whenever that song came out the
thing is is there were other white
singers that sounded like that yeah okay
[__] uh what was his name the the
[__] Scottish guy who [__] did
um oh man you know who I'm talking about
Scottish guy no I don't
actually oh [__] give me a little give
me a few more clues give me some more
clues oh man need some context I'm
trying to think of the
songs I'll remember it in a minute okay
it's from the
60s okay SC guy from the 60s curly
hair
um Donovan no um he was kind of like a
Scottish version of [__] Wayne Newton
and Robert G he was godamn and kind of
uh
um he okay he [__] elvir and put her
in the [__] hospital with some
stitches in her ass he had a [__] big
ass
dick how did how did Cassandra feel
about that I don't know she she talked
about it on the Howard Stern Show long
long time ago she's like yeah he sent me
to the hospital yeah with that big he
busted it open she had to go to the
hospital get sketches in it Zach says
this is Tom Jones Tom Jones exactly oh
right I I will tell you one thing Tom
Jones is Tom Jones sounding black he's
Welsh he was Welsh that's right he's
from Swansea not Scotland but Welsh he's
he's from uh Swansea right I've been
there you could I lived in Wales for for
for the genre of music he was singing at
the time back in the 60s if you were to
just hear him and not see him you would
probably think that was that was 1960s
black guy singing it no Tom Joe's was a
white dude and but he was [__]
packing like a brother [__]
say cassander Peterson also known as
[__] elvirus said it was like a
[__] beer
can yeah well Tom Jones was very known
for um having women throw panties at him
on stage that was kind of his thing yeah
he had this bulge in his pants it wasn't
padding that was real that wasn't like
you know tube St or yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah Tom Jones exactly thank you much
yeah I actually I like some of Tom Jong
yeah yeah didn't really think about him
before but like I said because I was
married to a Welsh guy for a long time
and I went you know I lived in Wales for
a while and I was back and forth and
they [__] love Tom Jones yeah he's a
legend well yeah well he's one of the I
mean Tom Jones Anthony Hopkins anybody
that's from W Katherine Zeta Jones um
anybody that's from Wales going to like
[__] own that [__] yeah and like I
said Tom Jones I think he might have
been I want to say he was from Swansea
but maybe that was kathern Zeta Jones
Jones was Tom Jones was kind of like uh
the the Welsh version of Elvis Presley
that was their version of Elvis Presley
and Mississippi Elvis is Elvis but
[__] yeah that was our version of
[__] Tom Jones yeah yeah they're
they're both quite dudes he had a good
[__] voice I will say that he could
sing I like some of his songs actually
yeah I do yeah no he could sing yeah he
could also perform yeah he was a great
Club performer I mean there's a reason
why he's still [__] famous yeah he's
good like why you know what I mean um he
was very charismatic like I said I don't
really know I don't really get the whole
like people throwing underwear at him
and stuff like that but it's just kind
of like [__] was sexy man girls were
[__] trying to woo him he was up on
stage I don't he's not my type I guess
but it was he had to be it was a man he
was a man of his time yeah he's a man of
his time but he does have a great voice
and I do like some those songs yeah you
know what I mean
yeah Victor says watch saltburn last
night uh Jacob ordi made me gay so there
you go that's uh what made him gay who
made well you just read it I I can't see
watch saltburn last night Jacob illori
is that how you pronounce it made me gay
okay that's what today's made made him
gay is you're always blaming your
gayness on these men well you know you
made you gay you
made okay your desire for these men okay
so made so Tom who do you blame your
heterosexuality on who do you blame your
heterosexuality on I'm going to go back
in my mind this should be good when did
you baby a kid me that was your when you
first realized that's when I realized
yeah okay you my babyit a kid me yeah
she she looked like [__]
uh
uh Princess Leia I showed Jenny the
pictures of her I got a picture of her
my mom took a picture of her when I was
a little kid she was probably about what
13 something like that yeah yeah she
looked like a little carye Fisher that
was Tom's first crush his babysitter
[__] loved her my baby she Liv how
old are you like five seven maybe seven
six seven she only lived like Three
Doors Down from me so whenever my mom
had to go somewhere she'd hand me over
to Kimmy and I was raised by kind of
semi- raised by for that little period
Kimmy and her friends they'd be in there
smoking pot listening to [__] red
zeppelin and [__] passing me around you
know I was like a little like here have
this baby here have him yeah yeah yeah
yeah Tom was their Pooky yeah I was like
a Pooky and they got the [__] this is
California you know what I mean they got
incense going and they're smoking pot
talking about boys and [__] I'm totally
just oblivious and they're just [__]
petting on me [__] love thank y yeah
she take my mom would give her money
she'd take me to the [__] uh MAA and
I'd see [__] Sinbad eye the tiger and
[__] all the little British [__]
fantasy movies
and
um
took me to see [__] amville
horror because they didn't care about
age that was 1979 yeah amville that be
scared the crap out of me when I was a
kid holy crap Amy Vore would have been
eight yeah I think I was seven yeah when
that movie came out so you must have
been a little bit older oh no yeah i'
have been i' been 10 I was seven I was
10 when that movie came out that movie
scared the [__] out of me when I was a
kid holy crap it's not scary now like if
you watch it obviously but it's like
back in the day either nine or 10 it
gave me nightmares when I was little
Kimmy was only just a little bit older
than me when I was 10 she was probably
about 14 or
15 yeah yeah and that was how you first
knew that you were yeah [__] I loved
Gibby she's gonna be my wife someday no
I didn't think of it that way I was too
young to think of it like that and
[__] uh one day I was uh it I know it
ended she broke up with me oh no yeah I
was standing there on a side a sidewalk
with [__] Jimmy and Mike [__] my
boys that lived a couple little budes my
other little buddies yeah I grew up with
them
too Jim ended up being a [__] uh CHP
California Highway Patrol and [__] I
was standing out there in the [__]
street with him we had [__] I had my
swim bicycle and [__] we were probably
doing ramps and thinking you were cool
as [__] thinking I was [__] evil
coneval and [__] and Kimmy comes out
with some other dude they get in his car
and leave and I was just like oh [__] he
had a car and [__] Jimmy goes was he
got your
girlfriend and Tom's heart was broken I
was like yeah that day yeah and then he
instantly forgot about
it yeah cuz that's how little boys
that's how it is yeah yeah okay and I
forgot about it well because at that age
yeah largely like boys I kind of feel
like they still think girls are icky
right um although the weird thing about
it is that I didn't think girls that
were older than me were icky right but
girls my age younger were icky if they
were older than me and [__]
sophisticated from my point of view I
was all about it oh okay and I was you
know even when I was like six seven
eight I'm [__] checking out chicks
with big tits and [__] looking at
booty and all I I was like full grown
man I was like yeah I want I want to get
that yeah yeah it just buil it's just
built into you well weirdly um some boys
don't you know like Oscar and Zach
they're not built that way but I just I
don't know if it's hormonal or genetic
or what I can't explain it it just it's
the way it developed now Jen was reading
Rob hord's book it's over here he
developed a little bit differently he
was um jerking off with a bunch of
little boys and he was a little boy and
he got fixated on that that was the way
he and he knew he said he knew from very
very young that he was gay very very
young it didn't that didn't happen with
me so just yeah well like I said it was
a different experience for you yeah
totally focused on on on girls that were
older than
me yeah you know what's interesting is
that when I was a kid even when I was
young like first grade second grade so
like six seven years old I always had
crushes on boys but I also was real
into this is like maybe I shouldn't say
this but I used to find my dad's porn
mags yeah they weren't bad they were
just like play well he had Penthouse
yeah he didn't hide him that good yeah
um so I found those and I found those
intriguing also yeah so it's just a
sexual um situation so I kind of felt
like like yeah H yeah situation
yeah so it was maybe I don't know maybe
that was a whole buy thing when I was
younger cuz I was kind of like yeah
pressures on boys but look at this money
coming what did it say is it really yeah
I can't I can't see it wa down there who
thank you very much Victor Victor Victor
okay yeah best horror or any movie of
2023 I say where're evil lks uh then
talk to me um I yeah I don't think I'm
going to argue with you on where evil
lurks I think
think of of the movies that I've seen in
2023 I think that might be my favorite
although wait did infinity pool will
come out in 2023 or 2022 because that
might be number one or number two but
when where evil lurks was fantastic if
you haven't seen it yet oh and also see
the see that guy's other movie terrified
from 2017 that is also [__] fantastic
really really good it's um it was on
shutter I don't know if it still is I
just finished my whole history of Horror
like essay so I'm thinking about like
all these movies I was going to say
Barbarian but I think that was
2022 CU I think that was my favorite
horror movie of 2022 maybe there's a lot
of good comments I don't know I have to
go wait a minute okay talking about who
made what gay and [__] like that
everybody oh wait oh [__] I got way
behind way behind Okay so yeah no wonder
if my mom loved Tom Jones yeah he's a
good singer I really you know all all I
like all those songs and like I said I
lived in Wales for a while they [__]
love him over there you know what I mean
he's
like the the hometown boy that made good
and they just they play him in the pubs
and everything like or they did back in
the mid 2000s because that was the last
or the late 2000s that was the last time
I went over
there Oracle says every Welshman is
convinced he's a great singer and is
usually right yeah um I don't know if I
ever said this on the show but my ex
husband's Uncle what was his name Wayne
[__] now I can't remember it was a long
time ago
but he used to sing in pubs over there
and he had a really good voice he kind
of did sound like Rod Stewart now that
you're like mentioning it and a lot of
people said that but yeah he would go
around and do like he would sing it uh
pubs like in the local area and
sometimes like farther a field and stuff
but yeah a lot of them can sing I don't
I don't know what it is
but I just thought that was funny oh
Victor says 1991 Kean Reeves made me gay
oh okay I can see that I can see that
he's a pretty good-looking dude he's
still a good-looking dude I think
um Z says hereditary gave me 70s horror
movie Vibes when I first saw it I
probably told you guys this before but
hereditary because you guys know I'm a
horror dork so I've seen like everything
not everything but you know a
lot when I saw that movie it [__] it
made me
feel
so bad and yet I was like that yes
that's what I've wanted to feel from a
horror movie since I was a child that's
the first time I'd felt that bad from a
horror movie since I was a kid and I
loved it on the other hand I did not
want to [__] watch that movie again I
did eventually but it took like two
years for me to like get my [__] [__]
up to watch it because I was like I
don't want to feel that shitty again but
on the other hand man what a good
[__] movie that was it really really
[__] stressed me out it was so bad um
but yeah let's see um where they're all
talking about what made him gay 1991 ke
Reeves made him gay that yeah who who
who who made that that was uh who who
said that Victor Victor 1981 Victor
every time you [__] say what made you
gay it's always something different
every time Jeffy art said Dukes of
Hazard made me real gay Jeff well like
the the early one like with John
Schneider and yeah I know he talking
about who was that the Tom W hat yeah
because they had the dam tight tight
jeans acid wash jeans and [__] yeah and
U I used to watch that when I was car
and um oh what's her name Daisy may I
think is her name was she was walking
around them [__] um cut off [__]
shorts with nylons and [__] boots
cowboy boots so that may have helped
make me straight really yeah Jeffy art
said men in tight jeans and
boots little Fiery Heart Right it has
something for everybody in that one so
uh but Daisy Duke that's what her name
was Daisy Duke yeah with the little
shorts on yeah yeah although I haven't
seen that in a long time you probably
see it now there probably nothing to it
but back in the days [__] she had
really good legs for the
time that [__] we should probably
rewatch that one of these days I don't
know if I could sit through it but it
was [__] silly all those shows back
then were very
silly I used to watch it when I was a
kid I kind of was like oh John
Schneider's kind of cute but it's like I
wasn't really like I said I was more to
like the new wave Punk kind of stuff
boss hos
bog and then they had an enus [__]
spin-off [__] program where he was
the star of it remember that enus he cop
that's right he was the cop he did get a
spin-off did he got a spinoff I don't
think it was super successful though was
it no but I remember seeing it as a kid
so I like it it better than the [__]
Dukes of Hazard it was it was good it's
kind of like uh Andy Griffith kind of
okay kind of which I was of but you know
television was terrible man it really
was it was [__] terrible mod nowadays
like yeah go back and watch some [__]
70s and ' 80s TV and then come back to
me it was meant to make you stupid that
[__] was [__] dumb so bad it's just
like cringeworthy there was no content
in it no intellectual content the idea
was to suck every bit of [__]
intelligence out of your
brain it [__] made you dumber
watching that [__] it was fun though
Fantasy
Island I did like Fantasy Island well
because that had a mystery aspect and I
was into that CU I like creepy [__] yeah
yeah it's the same reason that I when I
was little I like Scooby-Doo and all
that kind of stuff like cuz I like I
always like creepy [__] I like The Adams
Family when I was little you know
anything that had anything to do with
anything creepy I was into it um Victor
says I loved Barbarian I did too God
damn what a good [__] movie that was
I I haven't seen it yet I want to see it
um I know said I'd like it huh you might
okay um I do want you to see X though
um but cuz I think you'll really dig
that because like I said that's like a
throwback slasher but it's like a 70s
porn shoot that where they all get
murdered and like really really
graphically horrible ways and it's
really good and Mia uh Mia goth from
infinity pool is in it yeah um so she's
been a lot of I I kind of feel like
she's Our Generations well not my
Generations obviously but the younger
generation scream Queen CU she's been a
lot of like cool horror movies and she's
a great [__] actress some people said
she should get an Oscar for Pearl but
nobody's going to give Oscars for horror
movies not yet anyway but we're getting
there we're getting there um yeah so let
me see murder Hornet said I remember
being hetero when I found my dad's VHS
Porn Stash yeah yeah um and then Alison
Wonderland said I'm way too hetero for
my own good yeah um yeah it's weird
because I kind of feel like like I said
I'm Jenny's open to [__] yeah you I'm
just kind of like she she's she's into
guys uh generally but you know what I
mean she's she she likes some chicks too
you know just I'm kind of like whatever
yeah she's picky on both ends yeah yeah
she's picking for the one and if I'm
gonna cuz he asked me the other night
he's like what if I'm not here like what
porn are you watching like like I don't
watch a lot of porn but I like if it's
going to be it's going to be chicks I
don't really or gay porn I like gay porn
Chi but it's like it's usually going to
be chicks here's the thing though all of
my exes did that same thing yeah and
they were straight or you know that
mostly straight I gu I would say because
but I I understand it understand how the
porn industry Works heteros male
heterosexual porn is oriented for a
heterosexual male viewer yeah it's
focusing on stuff that women really
aren't interested in right women are
more interested in heterosexual women
are more interested in the
guy and also kind of the situation and
what's going on yeah I like the whole
what's happening right more than the
actual more than the people and when
you're when you look at generic straight
porn of of
today the male performers are very
boring and they don't show them much
they're not in shot the dicks in shot
but that's it you don't see the guy's
face you don't see his Expressions you
don't see what's going on well those
guys are kind of like the mopes of the
industry most of them their whole job is
just to remain hard it's all focused on
the woman so a heterosexual female is
not going to really be appeal to that
too much what would be what would be
more appealing to a a straight woman is
gay porn because now you they're
showcasing two dudes she likes to see
them both they're showcasing what the
dudes are doing also the quality of the
performers is a lot better they tend to
be jacked they're in better better
condition I
mean I'm not going to [__] [__] on
[__] straight male performers it's
just that any guy who can be hard can do
that well they're not the focus they're
not the focus they're more like an
extra in gay category those dudes first
of all they're a lot better physical
they are the focus they're the focus and
they're making a lot more money than the
than the straight
guys and here's the thing I know some of
them guys one of those guys and they are
straight they're fake and gay they're
taking all kinds because you make more
money you make a lot more money in gay
porn than in straight porn yeah and
they're taking something called triix
which is an injectable you can inject
right into your dick and you'll be hard
no matter what you could do surgery on a
dick after you [__] inject somebody
with
tryx uh they just I should I get some of
that yeah they're
bodybuilders they're making real
money um they make 10
times what a [__] straight male
performers is going to
make so a woman be more interested in
that or a lesbian form they like that
too I like that because the girls there
are both being kind of showcased and a
woman can kind of like relate to kind of
what's going on and it's kind of a
naughty thing and she kind of projects
herself into the situation where she can
kind of canive with them like it's like
an empathy type thing which pretty much
every every one of my exes including my
ex-wife was like
that and my ex-wife was straight but she
liked lesbian porn I think a lot of
women do well like I said she thought a
lot of the guys were gross the straight
guys but the uh the the the gay muscle
porn guys she likeed those too but there
it's harder for a woman to find that
back in those days they could probably
find it easier Now searches would be a
lot easier inter I kind of feel like um
I sort of like maybe the situation
behind it more than but yeah I don't
really like a lot of just generic
straight porn because it's kind of
boring and it's like not really focused
on I'm straight and I'm the same way
most of it's boring yeah I don't really
like it too generic like I said if I'm
going to look at something to kind of
like get in the mood or something it's
generally going to be girls yeah or it's
going to be something where the dude's
not really um that prominent yeah well a
lot of times just solo female is good
enough that's good too [__] just all
all yeah [__] one of the hottest videos
we ever watched yeah was and I didn't
even know that I was going to be into
this until we just stumbled across it
was the lactating video remember that
one that we found I still remember that
one I was like that was super hot yeah
yeah that was just about a Japanese girl
sitting in a chair and a dude [__]
milking her it was I thought it was
another girl actually I thought I didn't
think there was any it was a guy but you
couldn't see his face it just his hands
yeah see which is f and some of it's
like in slow motion and it's on a black
background yeah it was it was it was
good well some of the Japanese stuff is
good I kind of like a lot of those like
milking videos too where like a doodle
just put the dick you can't see the dude
but you just put his dick through the
hole of the board and she's like milk in
it said I kind of like when you can't
really see the dude like I said unless
it's gay porn then that's cool then you
want to focus on that but like straight
porn I'm like yeah I don't really want
to see them yeah now of course got a lot
of got a lot of my gay friends in here
and gay gay fans um the thing the thing
the straight guy interpretation of the
gay thing it it's doesn't really re
resonate with straight guys
because straight guys are are kind of
just built to be focused on the things
that are opposite now the things that we
don't have which would be like
femininity and feminine femin and stuff
we we're really into
that when a straight guy sees gay stuff
it's kind of odd to us because you see
two of the same things we don't really
get off on sameness I guess in the same
way
that gay guys would I don't really know
what a gay guy experiences when they see
that material because I've watched it
because I'm in the industry you know I
me [__] I actually had offers to get
involved in that yeah I mean we watch
all kind of stuff so I wanted to know
exactly what that entailed and how that
how it's shoted and [__] like that it is
better quality it is yeah yeah um
because
the when you're making when you're
producing and and marketing
pornography the main buyer is
male women will watch it but they won't
buy it nah the buyer is male okay
so if you're a higher quality guy you're
GNA have to appeal to the male audience
which means that's gay [__] yeah because
that's what like Mone come from I mean
now if because women will are if they're
going to pay for something it'll
probably be like erotica like written
erotica yeah written right so um I like
because I like that I like that more
than visual actually so like gay product
doesn't speak to straight guys we don't
really there's an exception
though
lyrics a gay man can write some badass
[__] lyrics man especially if it's
[__] Top lyrics like hyper masculine
[__] like [__] um uh uh Rob howford
and Judas Priest lyrics going all the
way back to the 1970s talking about
Godlike dudes coming from the [__]
Sky to [__] punish people for their
evil that they've done and yeah just all
kinds of and just the way he worded
things that will speak to a straight guy
cuz I guess in that particular sense
Jen's not done with a book I want to
read to read his his I should just read
the whole thing to you you could read it
to me yeah that' be great she reached me
some my vision's [__] not as good as
it was yeah but um the it would [__]
um something about Rob uh earned a lot
of respect he he knows what guy's like
he can make [__] sound [__] cool as
[__] now could he talk me out of ass I
don't think so oh I don't know about
that but I would send him a dick pick
I'd send rob a dick pick [__] right
just out of respect here you go rob
here's a dick pick don't do it
unsolicited no no well yeah I might look
like a cheap [__] if I did that well
yeah you would yeah yeah but ask him
first I would love to meet Rob I'd love
to hang out with Rob howford how cool
would that be if you like you're like no
offense but can I send you a dick pick
and then he said yes and it's like oh my
God that would be awesome Mr hord may I
uh out of respect for you and your work
uh that I've been enjoying enjoying your
work over the past [__] 30 years may
I send you 30 something years may I send
you a
dickpic may I yeah may I send you a
dickpick just go ahead my son [__]
boom go ahead my son there you go well I
mean like I said at least you're asking
yeah many dudes that do that to women do
not ask they just send you the [__] and
you open your message and you're like
he's he's a Lea he's a leather daddy
though he's a leather daddy though he's
he's not he's not feminite about that
he's like you're supposed he's supposed
to get dick
piics he's supposed to that's right
that's demands that's right yeah he's
he's a top
yeah probably want some ass pictures too
that's my tribute yeah yeah right well
you have a cute ass yeah I S that you
have a you have a nice day little
[__] monkey ass you don't what you're
monkey ass little bitty [__] ass hold
on it's
per I like it hold on let me go to
restroom I need another drink too okay
but you know what the same thing
whenever yeah that was good actually I
like that yeah Victor said hereditary
was so good Midsummer too yeah both of
those movies I mean I I like hereditary
I think is probably one of my favorite
if not my favorite horror movie from the
last 20 years I saw in the theater and I
was just kind of
like I don't know man I felt like I got
hit by a [__] plus and I know that
like other people didn't feel like that
it's just it's all subjective obviously
but it's like that movie [__] me up I
had nightmares about that [__] and I
never have nightmares about stuff I
think the last time that that happened
to me that I had a nightmares about a
horror movie was like the ring from 2002
that gave me nightmares for a couple of
days but hereditary oh God it just it
made me feel
awful but on the other hand I was just
kind of like that's awesome though
because that's what horror is supposed
to do because I watch horror movies all
day every day you know what I mean
pretty much and it's just kind of like I
just I keep waiting for that one that's
just going to make me feel like [__] you
know what I mean cuz that's what it's
supposed to to do and that one did that
that one did that so much so that it's
just like I said it took me two years I
was like I really want to watch it again
but I kind of don't because I was like I
felt so [__] awful after the first
time I saw it it
was awful but it's so good it's so good
there's just it's
so there's so many layers to it like so
much thought was put into it and I just
[__] love that msar was also great
it's funny because Tom did not like
hereditary he likes it better now that
he's seen it a couple more times um but
we saw in the theater together and he's
like I don't really like that but um you
know he appreciates it now more because
I own it so we've watched it one or two
more times since then but um midamar we
saw that in the theater and he loved
that he loved that and we've watched
that a couple more times since then and
that's again it's it's completely
different than hereditary but it's also
its own thing and it's just like I love
how I love how AR Aster he just puts all
this stuff in the
background that um kind of informs the
story but like without anything being
super overt I love that has anybody seen
Bo is afraid cuz I know that was Ari
Aster's new one and I kind of heard like
mixed reviews of it and I've been
wanting to watch it but I haven't seen
it yet I know it's not a straight horror
movie I know it's kind of more of a it's
like a black comedy or something and I'm
not real sure so I'll event I'll get
around to it but I haven't seen it yet
but I don't know if any of you guys have
seen it and can tell me yay or
nay Victor says actually I remember
thinking Vasquez from Aliens was cute
when I was a kid I didn't realize
Vasquez was a chick so Vasquez may be
straight I love it I love her actually I
love I love that character Allison uh
also says I love gay porn yeah I do too
I'm I generally
prefer um lesbian porn but gay porn is
good too and like I said it's not really
I'm just open to pretty much anything
I'm just kind of like I like the
situation you know what I mean a lot of
times it's not even the people that are
in it it's the context like what's going
on in The Wider
situation you know I kind of like that
better like I said I don't even remember
when we watch those lactation videos I
don't remember what those [__] people
looked like I just liked the whole
situation behind it cuz I was like wow
that's awesome you know what I mean like
I never really thought that that would
be hot but I was like that's pretty hot
no I was saying that Victor was saying
that um that he had a um that he
remembered thinking Vasquez from Aliens
was cute when he was a kid and didn't
realize that that was a chick so that so
maybe she made him straight yeah she
straight for a second yeah I
guess Allison says okay guys I'm gonna
bow out for tonight this podcast made me
gay a have a good one alisan have a good
weekend um happy 2024 yeah that's right
have a good New Year we'll probably be
back on um well we're going to do we'll
do a movie review on New Year's Day like
we usually would on Monday I don't know
what movie it's going to be yet because
do you want to do little big man or do
you want to watch something else just do
little big man okay because we watched
little big man the other something but
with Dustin Hoffman so we might talk
about that on Monday yeah Alison
Wonderland says she loves gay porn
because I like the body parts yeah yeah
I mean I like dicks too I'm just I like
dicks I like I like all the parts
murder Hornet said I have a shower
masturbating fetish wa who said that
yeah murder Hornet yeah I could see that
there's a lot of videos like that yeah
like people masturbating the shower like
in the bathtub or whatever there's a lot
of those um I don't know since we
started doing like outdoor stuff it's
like I kind of like the public stuff
depending on what it is like some of
it's dumb but you know what I mean the
the you could almost get caught [__] we
had to do a store video were you walking
down a store doing upskirts and [__]
yeah you're [__] flashing those are
like pretty popular I is actually what
it is is you know flashing streams are
pretty popular yeah we you're in the
grocery store like nobody's in that
Island when you're in a restaurant
you're [__] popping your titties out
real quick and you're like I'm just
watching you you'll get money that way
yeah but I don't know uh
um I think the best site for that is
like some of that [__] that comes off an
xHamster that server you got to have a
good connection with your
phone I just run the phone with you and
you're you're eating and [__] popping
your titties out every now and then
those are token sites though
yeah I don't know we'll maybe we'll
consider it one of these days I do kind
of like it but we got other income
streams right now just that's
true we got to call that
woman yeah we'll see we'll see what
she's up to yeah I know once once uh
after the New Year everything's kind of
shut down right now yeah cuz it's the
week between the holidays you know what
I mean yeah yeah Oscar said that he saw
Bo is afraid Okay saw it again Bo is
afraid the new AR Aster movie okay
newish yeah uh said saw it again
recently I liked it a lot better than
when I saw it in theaters yeah it's I
really need to watch it because I love
Ari aser I've Loved all of his stuff and
I just heard mixed reviews of that one
because people like ah it wasn't a
straight horror movie or something like
that but I tend to like things that are
not one genre or the other so I might
really dig it we'll see Zach says actors
in gay porn seem to have way more fun
and enjoy themselves a lot more too if
you ask
me they do look like they're having a
better time some of the muscle [__] that
I saw those are straight guys [__]
around having [__] fun but they're
laughing at each other
but I'm like yeah man [__] you're
trying to make [__] light of a
ridiculous situation some of the [__]
that they're doing in those houses
because they're on
tryx yeah you know I mean you're going
to stay hard whether you're [__]
turned on or not those dudes are just
there walk around doing goofy [__]
inside the [__] house
and trying to beat each other up and
then they [__] doing [__] weird
[__] I'm not going to talk about it on a
[__] live stream I get censored might
be get demonetized we've already been
demonetized trust me for those you I
think every one of our side has been
demonetized for those of you who are not
regular [__] uh I got a friend who
he's another bodybuilder who does that
[__] gay for pay yeah as they call it
yeah he does that [__] and uh
if me and him did some steroid deals and
stuff but he was like Hey man we should
work together we make all kinds of money
like no I'm good man how much would it
take for you to do it Tom thousands
motorcycle money motorcycle money
motorcycle yeah [__]
um but no he sent me some clips of what
he was doing I was like n I'm good
bro it's basically
BDSM but you know him roughing up twinks
okay
yeah yeah you know twinks and
trans that's another thing I like is
especially because we've kind of gone
off into pay for it and [__] in the
we've kind of gone off into like a lot
of the animated porn yeah which I kind
of like cuz I said you know a lot of
Fooda Fooda animation yeah I like I like
all the Fooda stuff yeah Fooda and I
like that I like that there's like uh
you can go on it's called Uh ru 34 is
that's called Rule 34 yeah yeah that's
yeah I think it's rule 34.net I think I
don't remember what and it's nothing but
3D animated stuff and creators are
putting it up there you can see I like a
lot of that they're stealing it and they
had all kinds of World of Warcraft
videos like monster like like girls
getting [__] by werewolves and stuff
I'm like I'm kind of into this well
their female monsters also have having
sex with monsters and [__] crazy [__]
fairies or elves or whatever and elves
with [__] minur like all right minur
and werewolves I like it well it's not
real people so it's just kind of like
you know no but some of the animation's
real
good yeah and they got some other like
individual artists that'll [__] bring
some crazy [__] to life too uh what was
that guy's name that oh yeah that guy
that used to like he has a patreon I
can't remember what his name is though
but you can get um cuz some of the
animation is not great yeah but this
dude does like really Stu like it's very
like artistic Butch that's right General
but that's name he goes yeah his shit's
good I like that stuff the clips are
only like a couple minutes long but he
puts a lot of but yeah they're only like
three minutes long but he'll clip them
people will compile them into like two
hour long videos and me and Jenna have
that [__] running in the back when we're
working stream mate we running in the
background sometimes and it's wild [__]
it's video game characters having sex uh
anime characters [__] from from video
games um I think that's mostly it video
games and it's like fantasy characters
anime characters and stuff you know
Laura Croft will be some of them and
[__] [__] black widow and stuff and
like I said I do like a lot of the kind
of monster stuff so I'm kind of getting
more into like the fantasy Monsters and
Aliens yeah like I said and I and I like
the Fooda stuff as well yeah the Fooda
Fooda we see when I like I like the food
of whenever a guy makes a video one of
these big creators he'll do the straight
version he'll a Fooda version where he
takes the female and turns her into a
it's a Japanese World it means a
Japanese word it means dick
girl and a Fooda is not necessarily a
trans a Fooda is born of Fooda in
[__] Japanese thinking it's just a
whole different thing yeah sometimes it
has it's like a has male and female
genitalia but it's a girl that has a
dick but it's not any old dick it's like
a 16 17 inch long [__] dick yeah yeah
it's a it's a it's a it's a it's a
unicorn creature so the creators will
make a straight version and a and a
Fooda version of it so those will kind
of get mix mixed into the into the
[__]
compilations and it's like T
Fooda or yeah I like kind of weird
[__] well like I said I kind of like it
because you couldn't really do that
necessarily with real people but if
somebody makes them with animation you
can do all kind of crazy [__] and it's
like that's way cooler I like that like
the imaginative and and then there's
like these weird reboots like Catwoman
as a Fooda yeah see I like that yeah
having sex with Wonder Woman as a Fooda
oh yeah we watched that one there's all
kind that was a good one actually I like
that one they're beating each other up
and [__] I like that one yeah so
little take like known characters and
make like a Fooda version you know Fooda
Catwoman having sex with a horse oh yeah
that's another one yeah that's right
well was that part of the same video
like there two different versions oh
okay cuz I thought she banged Wonder
Woman and then she's like hey look a
horse I was like I don't that was a
different episode okay it's all made in
episodes yeah it's just wild [__] man
just Blended together yeah I kind of
like that well I think World of Warcraft
makes more sense to me because they're
in a Dungeons and Dragons type world
they're they're [__] you know mean
there's minotaurs and werewolves dragons
dragons having sex with women [__]
and then dragons having sex with nips
and elves and [__] and it's not real
people so it's like nobody's getting no
hurt or anything I'm watching this [__]
and I'm going I'm like the ancient
Romans would have loved this because
because they they drew this kind of [__]
saders having sex with she goats theyd
that was their version they didn't have
video games back then but if they had
they would have done the same exact
thing yeah but I like that little seder
children having sex with adults and [__]
they did all kinds of weird art back
then [__] Romans were totally
Unlimited in their
debauchery well I told you were they
crazy yeah the Roman were crazy they
also had [__] slavery and they killed
people for entertainment in an arena
okay but it just just to show you
[__] how crazy humans are and can
get but like you said they really seem
to have
not I mean they were pretty open about
like all kind of different like weird
sexual [__] like I said there's nothing
new no like people talk about like they
see some porn as like look at this crazy
[__] it's like yeah I'm sure the
probably the ancient Romans thought of
that ROM
far more
debed they probably thought of some [__]
that we haven't thought
of a lot crazier well the Romans had no
problem adding children to the mix which
[__] that's just totally unacceptable
well yeah but they had no problem with
that as it should be yeah so uh but you
know they were [__]
Savages so we were watching last night
Tom had left on uh Wang
and he had great YouTube channel I'm GNA
give a give a plug to Wang it's not the
kind of Wang that my gay fans like it's
a different kind of went it has an H in
it it has a w h a n g with an apostrophe
I mean he's pretty famous I feel like I
think he looks half Korean to me but
he's a real
cool Korean looking guy with long hair
looks like something out of a [__]
heavy metal band he kind of looks like
out of one of those Chinese or or or
Mongolian throat metal bands that's what
he looks like you heard those least yeah
like the woo yeah I know what you're
talking yeah the The Who that's what
it's called that was a [__] badass
[__] metal
band from
uh
Mongolia he looks like something out of
that a long hair and [__] and he does
the [__] greatest videos about old
internet culture from the '90s when we
were coming up gross [__] that happened
on the internet yeah that's what I was
going to say we watched a video last
night that he had done like a two or two
and a half hour compilation of all of
his shows that were demonetized by
YouTube so most of them were like gross
as [__] it is a epic classic go [__]
subscribe to Wang and watch his [__]
new two hour long video you it will have
I was going to say speaking of like
weird sexual [__] he was talking about
probably most people that have been on
the internet for any amount of time have
heard of blowfly girl yeah F girl yeah
cuz she's I feel like she was kind of
famous Zach's going for sure he knows
who Wang is yeah W [__] trip yeah and
um I'm GNA say so that story that she
wrote uh and I'm not going to go too
much I'm sure we've already been
demonetized at this point but um it's
basically about a girl that gets off on
um uh is there any way to put this
delicately I don't think there is um
putting maggots in her [__] yeah so you
know yeah so there's that it gets a lot
grosser than Chef yard comes up with
some good [__] he's like so Tom when you
get a new bike we know what happen
exactly y'all are setting me up for some
[__] [__] is he's like he got P look at
this [__] yeah look at this bu Zack's
[__] going with he did some gay for
pay or yeah y'all are y y'all are
[__] something else no I was actually
thinking about buying a new bike I want
to get a cruiser and I don't have a
cruiser I need I need a cruiser with a r
ride that I can ride two up on so I have
Jenny on the back and we can ride around
yeah cuz the bikes he has now are not I
mean I've written on them before but
they're not super conducive to a second
riter bu Zack will [__] back me up on
this he's got two of the bikes that I
have he's also got BS they're not good
two up they're they're are small bikes
[__] xbs are [__] TI I have ridden
on them but yeah man I feel [__]
there's a [__] The Rake is [__]
very Steep and the [__] wheel base is
very short it's just not a good two up
bike so I was thinking about getting a
cruiser
I either want to get a Harley
fatbob or an Indian uh the Indian Chief
look good and I got an IND I got an
Indian dealer right near
me but I tell you what bu
Zach that [__] um did you check out
that [__] Indian Scout I think it's
got 110 120 horsepower on it and it's
pretty light that dudes are making [__]
out of that Indian Scout that looked
pretty [__] cool it's uh it's liquid
cooled but still the way they executed
it I I thought it looked [__] good
um the chief is air cooled but it's got
GPS built into the [__] instrument
cluster and it's just got a single
[__] cluster like that they look
good the the Harley Sportster
R I like that too and that's also got
[__] GPS on the instrument cluster
the problem with the [__] sports star
R is that
that's set up for solo riding it might
as well just be a [__] bule uh I
can't go too up on that with her I
wanted something that was kind of like
kind of like a bobber that I could go
two up on and if I wanted to I could
attach some bags to
it so that's either going to be a Fat
Bob a [__] Indian chief or an Indian
Scout
and the Scout is kind of closer up to
the top of the [__] pile because of
what Indian Scout is offering for the
price you can get those pretty [__]
cheap they look great and they offer a
[__] lot who is that some somebody
sent us something thank you very much
Ian England cheers thank you thank you
very much than that's awesome Jeffy art
said I can see the title now Tom gets
his Indian Scout yeah if I get Indian
Scout that does not mean I got pegged on
video okay no we'll just leave it
ambiguous we'll leave this [__] ambig
we'll leave you guys wondering doesn't
mean that I can get financing for that
my [__] credit's good I'm I'm a
[__] credit I'm a credit Powerhouse I
got a [__] you do have really good
credit I got real good credit I have
Fair Credit but he has really good once
Jen once Jen's [__] uh other job
starts coming in I wanted to get one of
those
uh kia souls I like that car I I rented
one and drove well we need another car
car so I got to get a Kia as reliable as
it is it is almost 20 years old do look
great once I get that KIA rolling and
get that job rolling I could probably
look at getting it getting an Indian
Scout yeah yeah although I could get
some from Harley too it's just that
man the bikes that I like from Harley
new they want a lot for them and they
don't offer a whole lot on the spec
sheet Indians offering
more what's uh what's what's Zach what's
what's Zack bu saying about that Indian
does my maintenance for bule since they
don't have dealerships yet okay does he
like the Scout he say oh don't know said
I like the um the Indian FTR FTR which
one oh yeah the FTR yeah that's the Flat
Tracker I was looking at that too but
the thing is is we got bules that's
redundancy it's it's too similar to what
we have I want something I can go to to
up with it's that the Scout is that same
motor it's just in a [__] Cruiser
frame so I think I want an Indian scalp
also Zach says my great-grandfather
bought an Indian during the Great
Depression for five bucks and a gold
watch yeah it wouldn't surprise me
motorcycles weren't worth much back in
those areas there was like a bicycle
with a motor it wasn't much yeah
everyone was like yeah big
deal murder Hornet says hidden cameras
kind of Turn Me On yeah yeah he's talk
yeah yeah yeah I get it well like I said
it kind of depends on I don't know
there's a lot that it depends on I like
a lot of porn but it depends kind of on
the situation of it you know there's one
Tom showed me these ones where
apparently this dude is his wife or his
girlfriend I don't I don't know but um
they go to like this glory hole
situation and then like he tells his
friends and well this is the story
behind I don't know if that's true or
not but he tells his friends to like
stick their dicks in the hole and then
she sucks the dicks and then he also
sucks the dicks but they don't know and
it's like I kind of thought that was
cool but like I said it's probably
[__] because a lot of porn is
they're just making stuff
up but I don't know it just kind of
depends I don't I don't really know if
I'm G to like it until I actually watch
it I know that's not helpful but you
know it's not helpful I like a lot of
things but I'm not sure if I'm going to
like it till I watch it y'all are
talking about asteroid City yeah I've
been hearing a lot about that like is
that good is it wait is it a movie or a
series oh it's a movie okay on
Netflix I'm G to have to watch that I've
been hearing like a lot of people
talking about that and it sounds kind of
cool we'll watch it one of these days
we'll watch
it and let me
see yeah he likes bu Zack yeah like I
said we you know because we have another
Zach and he's he's gay Zack he probably
doesn't mind was
that um they're talking about a movie
called um asteroids city which is on
Netflix yeah I don't know that one which
a couple people I've seen like some
people talking about it so maybe we
should watch that but um Overlord DVD
which is a guy that I'll [__] listen
to I haven't spoken to him but I listen
to him and I really kind of trust his uh
[__] uh opinion on a lot of stuff
said that um there's a new movie that's
kind of like a ripoff of Star Wars
called Rebel
Moon oh yeah he was skeptical but he saw
he said he liked it it wasn't perfect he
said a lot of it been he could tell a
lot of it good [__] got edited
out but um the theatrical release he
thought it was good but he was also
saying that he thinks that a DVD
director's cut will come out that will
be even
better but um I wouldn't mind seeing
Rebel Moon okay I'll watch it yeah I
don't know if it's if it's at the
theater we can check but Victor says my
fetish is a girl in socks running around
a table on a freshly waxed floor while a
guy in a furry suit chases
her that's very specific isn't it like I
said I'm not real I don't know I can't
really it's just kind of like when
somebody asks me what my type is I'm
like I don't know until I see it I don't
know till I see it you know what I mean
yeah I'm just kind of laidback like that
I'm just kind of willing to let [__]
take its course and I'm like do I like
this do I not like this you know what I
mean I have to see it before I know if I
like it or not
yeah um Victor says asteroid said he was
boring all right Zach says my fetish is
naked men fair enough that was gayak not
stra yeah gayak yeah sorry I I I
neglected to yeah you got different
different Jeffy said I love this Kink
sharing yeah yeah bu Zack this Show's
been going on a long time these are all
regulars Zack That's my boy he's been on
the [__] show for [__] [__] how
long [__] I don't remember how long
Zach been on here you guys have been
here like for and you come and watch us
every single [__] time we're on which
is crazy yeah Zach Zach's my gay buddy
[__] I talk to him off the show too
sometimes we're trading photos and [__]
[__] just stupid [__] and just links
and stuff you know what I mean talk to
him sometimes and he's just a good
dude Oscar's been it's another one
that's [__] been on here for a long
time lot all these people have been on
the girls have been on here a long time
this is a Friday night is basically like
open lines Friday and it's all our
hardcore regulars really cuz we're just
drinking and talking we're just drinking
talking yeah [__] we don't even have
a topic no no topic we just talked about
whatever which is like I said that's why
it's my favorite show right of the week
some nights we we do this for only a few
hours then we got to split because we
got to go to the club afterwards but
this tonight we're not going to the club
so so we can get completely [__] we get
[__] face and be on long we the last one
we did I think was almost 4 hours was it
well the show that we did about twin
flames on Wednesday night yeah I think
we went no before that the last Friday
was oh the last yeah that [__] oh we
might have gone almost six hour six
hours like six hours well because we
were drinking I was like what I'm having
a good time we're not going anywhere I
don't have where to go so we just
[__] got load I don't have any place
to be yeah we just sit here and get
drunk and like talk to you guys I'm like
that's like I said this is people in the
Stream So we were just talking yeah it
didn't matter well like I said you know
we do a bunch of streams every week yeah
and um you know I have fun doing all of
them but this is the this is the funnest
one because there's no I don't have to
prepare for it I don't have to do any
research for it I don't have to I can
just like sit here and drink and like
hang out you know what I mean which is
fun Victor says he found the show in
2017 damn when he was delivering pizza
on the weekends in [__] nursing
school that's crazy we started the [__]
we started this show in
2016 yeah and if you haven't been here
for that long we started the show we
didn't we hadn't really thought about it
but you know I was a writer and I was
working as a graphic designer and stuff
and we were at this horror convention
thing yeah and we met another horror
writer um I can't [__] I can't remember
his name right now I'll remember it
later but um he's he's kind of wellknown
so he's like well you know I have a
podcast Network and he's like you guys
are really funny um you know your
interactions with one another so it's
like you should start a podcast yeah and
I forgot the guy's name um yeah I'll
think of it in a second yeah we were on
his Network for about couple months I
think so we thought about it and we're
like we are kind of funny yeah like you
like and we like to talk about True
Crime we like to talk about murders and
paranormal [__] and stuff like that I
had written some books and Tom's like
well that would probably help like
promote your books and stuff like that
so maybe we should do that and I was
like yeah okay so we first started doing
it now at first for the first couple of
years I think like for the first 200
episodes that we did we didn't appear on
camera right um basically it was just an
audio and then I just did like we did an
audio version that would go out on the
podcast Network and then for YouTube I
would do like kind of a slideshow kind
of thing and then the 200 episode we
were like oh we should do a special
event thing where we actually do a live
because I think a lot of people didn't
know what we looked like yeah at that
stage so we did a live stream IM was
pretty strange when they I know well see
that's the thing like whenever cuz
sometimes when I just listen to people
and I've only heard their voices and
then when I see them I'm like that is
it's never they're never what I expected
them to look like I'm really really bad
our first [__] live stream when they
saw us people were like this is what you
guys look like well see everyone it's
probably the same people are not good at
like at um estimating what a person's
going to look like from their voice I'm
not good at that I'm really not I've
never been right I don't think my whole
entire time like with you know I listen
to podcast sometime and then I see the
person I'm like that is absolutely not
what I expected that person to look like
at all we got a positive reception
though they kept coming
yeah so we did the live stream and then
I was like I thought I was going to be
nervous but yeah so I was used to just
like recording the [__] and like not
having my face on camera camera and [__]
like that and just being able to cut out
[__] I didn't like or whatever and I was
just like oh this is going to be so bad
like we're going to say all kind of
crazy [__] and I'm just it's just going
to be out there and I can't do anything
about it but when we did the live stream
like oh wait that this is better yeah
it's better L it's better yeah it is
actually a lot easier it's a lot easier
it's a lot easier because you get
feedback from a live crowd yeah yeah
yeah but I already knew that because I
was you know in high school I was a
drama
kid so I I was already used to [__]
working off a live live crowd I was
doing musicals and [__] lead roles in
musicals and then [__] doing plays
and [__] so this is before I join a
service so I already knew what a live
audience was like live audience is the
way to go that's why all these Hollywood
actors [__] say [__] it I hate making
movies I want to go back to [__]
theater like yeah I get it yeah because
it's instant gratification you feel when
you're making a movie you have to do the
same thing over and over and over again
and it's not even in sequence it's like
you don't see the whole thing put
together and you don't Crow's reaction
right you don't feel the reaction of the
people it just seems very unnatural to
me so in that way like I do admire
people that can
act good in movies because that must be
like a [__] nightmare yeah it's
robotic yeah so somebody that can still
make me believe that you're an actual
person like going through this actual
thing it's like that's amazing you know
although a lot of the um more indie
films like my boy makes
Brian I went to military school with
him movies like that are a little more
organic like dragged across concrete
yeah there's a script but there's actual
scenes in that movie where where two
actors can actually [__] hold like a
conversation something like a Marvel
flick no it's real quick Cuts they're
not saying much they're saying a few
things is terrible that's not not really
a theatrical
performance well sometimes I think the
best movies will do kind of like a um
like you would do in theater where they
bring all the actors together they put
them in a room and then they let them
rehearse for weeks and weeks so you get
used to your characters and you get used
to the way that you interact with one
another and then later you can film it
and then because you're so comfortable
with one another you can actually like
improvise and that comes off really well
because it's very organic it's very
naturalis and I think it comes out a lot
better watching some of the [__] that
Brian made like draged across concrete I
could tell they were kind of doing that
it's kind of like blackbox theater yeah
they're doing a little bit of and you
know that's the kind of [__] that
Tarantino was doing with like [__]
Reservoir Dogs there's a script but I
could also tell that some of these guys
are slightly ad living that they'll [__]
a line up but they save it and then they
keep that cut and they're like yeah we
like that that was good yeah so just
leave that in there right right which is
good because like I said that comes
across as like more and that's the way
theater actually is which I I love
theater I wouldn't want to get back into
it it's a lot of work but but I can see
how I like the instant gratification of
it yeah I can see that yeah Zach says
actually as of this spring I'll have
been a regular for six years yeah and
Oracle said it's a weekly party for the
cool kids yeah weekly part for cool kids
yeah murder Hornet said I wonder what
ever happened to Sandra yeah we wonder
that too Sandra went back to Germany I
thought she was already in Germany yeah
I don't know what happened Tammy said
sandre probably ate too much peanut
butter eating all that goddamn peanut
butter and then Victor said Sandra and
Tila ran off and started their own show
Tila might have been a catfish account
we never really verified who the [__] oh
thank you thank you Zach thank you Zach
let's fund that Indian he says thank you
very much thank you much Z thank you
very much that's awesome thank you I
want to get a [__] black Indian Scout
I think is what I'm going to get Tom are
excited about it about it it's a liquid
cooled it's a liquid cooled Cruiser
which kind of makes me hesitate but it
is an American
Cruiser and that's 110 horsepower on a
500lb
bike it's not
bad not
bad some people say well [__] man Indian
[__] that's actually [__] uh Victory
really you know what I mean some but no
it that that that that brand does have
an identity I think it's not like a
Japanese
brand I never thought of them as the
same thing well they're not but the
thing is like I'm super up on it the
Indian of today is not actually the same
company as the original Indian they did
buy that name but it it's not a direct
lineage they were gone for a long time
and for a while Indian was nothing
nothing but just a Harley-Davidson copy
I think they even used Harley-Davidson
engines I think in the 90s when they
first started to
resurrect
um like I said I don't have anything
against Harley it's just that Indian is
offering more right now for the
money Zach says there was a Scottish
girl who used to do gaming videos on
here and I always assumed she was a
total freckled redhead type deal nope
she was a fat nerdy brunette with
glasses I am always wrong like whenever
I you know listen to somebody that it's
just their voice yeah and then I see the
person it's never ever what I imagine
them look like I I don't think I've ever
been correct a single time ever and I
don't know if that I'm the only person
on that what one person that was weird
who was it um if any of you guys watch
what is that channel called lazy
masquerade where he does like all these
creepy internet Mysteries and like
creepy missing person stuff he's I think
he's is he British or Australian I can't
remember but he lives in Japan and so he
does like a lot of these and he doesn't
post super often but he does like really
good videos and I had never seen him I
only heard his voice and I I don't know
I don't know if I really pictured him
looking a particular way but when I saw
what he looked like I was like that
wasn't what I was imagining at all he
looks completely different to what I
thought that he would look like he's
super cute but I didn't think that that
was what he looked like I was picturing
something completely different uh murder
Hornet said Tom did you notice the VA
check cost of living gave us over
$300 no I didn't yeah well I've noticed
that the check today was bigger yeah cuz
he got paid tonight you got paid tonight
yeah because he usually gets paid on the
first but the first is a holiday and
it's Monday so usually if it's I got an
extra 200 bucks for getting [__]
married to this chick Point yeah to this
chick to this [__] right here yeah this
chick right
here 200 for that wow I'm worth $200
whole dollars we got to buy a car
[__] yeah we do [__] uh got got
200 for that and then I did notice
there's some more money but I had money
in my my account I'm not [__]
spending myself dry you know we Haven
math I mean we haven't been spending a
lot the last year tomorrow we're going
to go to the [__] tomorrow we're
going to Chinese buffet okay [__] we
going to get we going to Chinese I mean
we spent a little bit over Christmas
yeah like you know we got each other
some nice presents and yeah guys and
stuff like that but we haven't really
been we haven't been going out out a
huge amount yeah past couple weeks
honestly I haven't really been spending
anything other than I bought you some
stuff for Christmas but other than that
I've just been buying like yeah just
regular sh like cat food and shampoo and
[__] like that I bought anything yeah
Jen's got a new client hanging so um
yeah if she they say yeah we want to do
business with you but we we have to
clear it to the president of this
company if she gets that client man
that's [__] that's going to be a huge
help it's going to be quite a
windfall and uh that would be great cuz
that's going to be all remote work and
part-time and part yeah and this house
got to be paid well yeah yeah this is a
$475,000 home yeah in Florida nice
twostory house I got it [__] financed
but I want to [__] get
some the value went up so I I My Equity
in it is [__] better than it was you
watch how us white boys know how to
[__] play this game okay I'm [__]
we know how to [__] work our [__]
lines of credit I want to sell this
house and then through the sale have
enough Le left over to where me and Jen
moved to the [__] Philippines yeah
we've been talking about that in the
Philippines my VA money alone would make
me a very wealthy
man see I like that idea yeah I like any
country I can live in where I can just
be like Le yeah we could still do the
show and everything so you guys wouldn't
even care all right I could have a house
built in the Philippines because I can
still do the show I would still do the
show because I like doing the show yeah
and uh as far as I can tell man up in
the Philippines they got goth clubs they
got fetish clubs they got all kinds of
[__] going on there we still have a good
time and they speak English and [__]
I could [__] I already speak [__]
three languages I could just learn
Tagalog if I had to but I think I I
think mostly country bump can speak
Tagalog everybody seems to [__] speak
English there but I wouldn't mind moving
to the Philippines if it's good at when
we're at that time you know what I mean
maybe 10 years from now it might not be
any good I don't [__] know I mean
we'll see how it goes but I know I can
get but it is something that sounds kind
of appealing it does sound appealing you
never lived overseas well you've lived
overseas you I live I lived in the UK
yeah you live in the UK in Wales yeah
which is I live in Brazil which is not
exactly I mean it's overseas obviously
but they still speak English and it's
not it's different but it's not that
different you know what I mean yeah I
wouldn't even need a big
place I don't either honestly even if it
was just a small place I mean this house
is big but it's like it's almost like
too big yeah we're not reusing at all
we're really not using most of it right
but it was more of just an investment
it's what we got offered yeah my old
landlord offered this to me yeah we kind
of bought it because the old landlord
was like hey why don't you buy this
house yeah well we were you're yeah move
over here and [__] then we bought
it so we'll see how it goes but we have
talked
about moving overseas somewhere where it
was cheaper where we could still do the
show I could still run my online
businesses I could still do all that
stuff but it would be like cheaper to
live yeah you know and I want to go
after my dad passed away well yeah I can
see that yeah my dad's not doing well
[__] you didn't call him today either no
I'll get him I'll get him you got to
call him tomorrow yeah he called him on
Christmas yeah he was in the hospital
and he was in the hospital yeah so let
me go to the
restro none of that surprising though we
all know that that's going to happen I
mean yeah I know yeah Oracle said um I
think I'm in danger of collapsing and
smashing my keyboard so I shall wander
off take care everybody you too um have
a good New Year's send scritches to
Pooky yeah got to have a like Pooky and
Bambi had need all the scritches I don't
even where are they I don't even know
where they are usually they are kind of
farting around in here
but um let's
see Zach says uh by the way I got a
couple actors roped into a short film
I'm going to be doing the spring
probably that's awesome it's a dark
comedy about a suicidal guy who goes on
a date with a weirdo hippie girl and the
whole thing just turns into a giant
farce that's actually sounds pretty
funny that sounds pretty funny uh Danny
says Philippines BJ bars
sure Christopher rucket said my girl is
building a house in the Philippines and
Victor says Art Bell moved to the
Philippines we were yeah it's just like
one of those it doesn't necessarily have
to be the Philippines but just at this
moment we were kind of researching and I
was just kind of like that seems to be a
good place to move at the the moment um
if you have as Tom does like he has um
VA money and that seems to be a good
place to move where you can get a lot
for your money you know what I mean so
I'm just kind of like yeah I'm open to
it I'm open to it I don't mind living
like living overseas it wouldn't bother
me at
all wouldn't bother me at all Victor
says I'm heading to Hawaii in the
morning going to go chill with some
friends for New York New Year's Eve oh
that's
awesome yeah murder oret says uh yeah
big paycheck this month
yeah you did I don't notice if you got
look because like I said you got a raise
when we got married yeah but um no I
noticed this month there was a lot in
there well it's j it's for January so
it's like the I guess it's the yearly
cost of living in cost of living
increase yeah cuz you did kind of look
cuz you showed me you got it and you
were like oh look at how much money is
in there it's the federal government
bribing veterans like me and murder
Hornet to keep from to keep us from
rebelling that's what it is they don't
want an uprising of [__]
well honestly that's a good way of doing
that if they wanted to do that they
would do that to everybody just like
give everybody like a living they're not
worried about the peasants because
they're not [__] armed and they don't
[__] know how to how to [__]
overthrow countries they're trying to
keep the veterans [__] happy [__]
send it down to the VFW and [__]
drink your brains out [__] just keep
them giving them money they they're
they're trying to pay us off go down to
the Oasis where your other where your
other girlfriend is my other girlfriend
is [__] hang out with the warlocks
until somebody [__] shoots me in the
back you it's like the Star Wars Cantina
down there oh [__] [__] yeah it is
kind of yeah yeah I've been there yeah
[__] I was telling I was telling I
was telling bule Zack about that about
what about the Oasis about the Oasis
yeah he has he has another wife down
there it's a funny
story some biker chicks down there
[__] like me but look they're busted
up right one shoulder higher than the
other and you know they're missing
they're just friends you know what I
mean but no they're giving me Rings this
my new husband I introduced you to my
other wife yeah yeah yeah she liked you
she like oh yeah she great
yeah she gave him a ring gave me a ring
yeah with a skull on it with a skull on
it yeah she goes that means me and you
were married I okay he's like all right
whatever yeah yeah we're married is she
on crack though not at that time yeah
well she's on and off crack she's on
she's on an off crack she's
on so I was kind of BL teas them about
yeah these AR pretty women okay but they
know it they know they know it it's just
like some dudes you know dudes you're
hanging out with I tease him about it
female dudes I tease him about going to
the Oasis and hanging out with his other
wife who gave him that ring which is
like very funny to me I did meet her one
time but I don't like I been there a
couple of times yeah yeah it's not a
kind of place you take a woman like
Jenny yeah it's like joh I it's two
country I don't mind it like hey the
booze is good and you know that's
usually all I care about it's like hey
have you got good cheap booze yeah nice
but it is a little rednecky for me yeah
a little rednecky for me like the music
is kind of unless Tom is also there and
he plays like some okay stuff because
you see um it's got a juke box that that
you can uh you can talk to using app
which surprises me because I would have
thought that when I'm DJing in there
[__] over the app there'll be some
cool [__] they the girls all like it
even the younger guys all like it yeah
that's right I'll start Ping some all
the old guys complain all the old guys
complain because they want to listen to
the Eagles and [__] stupid [__] like
that yeah [__] that [__] that I'm gonna
put some heavy metal on there put some
put some [__] um Dr Duran on there
nobody wants to hear Leonard skinnard
for the
F no no no right or whatever
but like the last time I was down there
yeah um I went down there in my car like
Tom had R down there on his motorcycle
um we were meeting some friends of ours
our friend Melissa and her boyfriend
were going to bike toober fest yeah in
Daytona and they stopped there because
they're like oh that's right near where
you guys live so it's like let's meet up
so we all went down there I drove in my
car Tom went on his bike and whoever was
DJing that day was all into the new
country yeah man and I was just kind of
like and I think I was I think I was
texting Zach at the time I just like oh
my God please kill me I hate this
[__] music I hate it like I can look
I can listen to like Old Country if you
want to play like some Johnny Cash or
some [__] Hank Williams or something
like that I'm down that's fine but it's
just kind of like this new [__] this new
[__] country I no thanks no thanks
I'll even listen to the Eagles okay I'm
not happy about it but you know I'll
even listen to Leonard skinnard I'm not
happy about it but I would rather listen
to that than new country whoever was
there that day was playing some new
country and I was not happy about
it I'm trying to pull up some videos of
what oh of the [__] yeah Victor said
new country is so [__] generic it's
God it's just it just gets on my [__]
nerves man that's that's the [__] one of
the bars that's one she cool I like her
she [__] loves J super cute she she's
all about boobs and she's like I think
maybe she wanted to have sex oh no she
to straight up and told me she straight
up and told me she's said you you and
your wife need to come hook up with me
we will have a [__] badass threesome
she says your wife's got some fantastic
titties I want to lick that [__] that's
what she
said that sounds like and I was like oh
really she showed me videos of her and
like other couples so she's not oh so
she's like oh no no she's a content
creator she's a content Creator she
knows that we're content creators
everyone know she's content yeah she
she's a biker content
creator all right no she loves so she
knows the deal no she loves you she's
like I got that she is hot I got that
she's hot [__] she's like first time
the first time I met her because I think
you had told me about you told her about
me and like had showed her pictures and
stuff so the first time I actually came
there she was all about it yeah yeah she
was trying to impress you well I have
showed her pictures you she know who you
were that's what I just said she s some
of our stuff yeah she's like oh you guys
man you guys [__] then she shown me
which some of the [__] she made I was
like okay yeah oh you saw some of the
stuff oh okay yeah you know she showed
me stuff that she's made oh all right
yeah yeah I didn't know that oh do you
still have it no no she showed it to me
on her device oh okay her and a I like I
want to see that her and some other
chick that was about like her and some
dude oh okay
yeah no so see we just have people she's
setting us porn
that's no empty threat or anything she's
she that's what she was trying to show
she like look I've done this [__] before
she's like we need to we need to get
together get get she seems cool yeah
she's cool you know she's cool Zach says
I think I'm going to Daytona in March
you'll have to take me to the Oasis oh
yeah yeah this is bu this is BU Zack
yeah yeah yeah I'll take you there yeah
like that's Spike week right I used to I
look I was born in Daytona I'm from
Daytona Beach I don't know if you know
that but uh yeah I was born in Daytona
Beach hospital I lived there pretty much
into my 20s so yeah I'm very familiar
with bike week my dad was kind of a into
the biker thing in in the bike
week times that that that's a week
before Bike Week a week after Bike Week
all right in that time no the Oasis is
banging it's a tiny place it's a tiny
place it's a dive well I don't know if
I'd go it's a dive it is but it's a bike
the bathroom's clean though yeah and it
it's famous in this area and the the the
Cabbage Patch is up about 15 20 mil from
here that's also a dive it's also a dive
it's kind of like the Cabbage Patch yeah
kind of like cabbage Cabbage Patch is
famous all the famous biker bars if you
actually go in them they're tiny and
they're Dives and their Dives yeah but I
think that's what people like like about
them and uh there's something I I
understand the appeal of the Oasis I've
been there like maybe a handful of times
Oasis is Florida is now a carry
state even when FL FL even when Florida
was not a Cary
State everybody in the Oasis that was a
biker was carrying a gun all of them
except me pretty much all of them I
didn't really care about that [__] um
when you go in there there's just
[__] cameras everywhere it's like
you're in a [__] bank like a crimes
getting ready to happen right nobody's
been killed in there there's been fights
not yet nobody's been killed recently I
think you know what I mean but those
dudes it's it's the Star Wars Cen well
you got to watch you got to watch I mean
it's not too bad if you go in there cuz
the the only if you're a biker you don't
have any [__] problems the only time
I've ever been in there has been like
afternoons right I don't go there at
night or anything women aren't going to
have a problem and bikers aren't going
to have a problem they all carrying guns
in there though but you have to be
comfortable with that I'm comfortable
with it so just know that I'm
comfortable with it doesn't bother me
bit but if you're from another country
or maybe another state where you're that
upsets
you that's not a place where you want to
be they're not violent they are
dangerous some of them some of them are
criminals but that's kind of like a
neutral zone in
there everybody in there is [__]
respected because anybody can kill
anybody well I kind of feel like kind
it's like the old west and well you get
a bik night in downtown Sanford yeah
with the warlocks who are a biker gang
mhm and the thing about it is that
they're yeah they're a gang they kill
they kill people but generally um as
long as you don't [__] with them and
it's like you don't give them any reason
to do anything to you they're not going
to do anything to you the same thing
that [__] uh bu Zack was talking
about when I mentioned that the if if a
biker gang [__] you up it's because you
deserved it I mean generally like I said
I grew up in Daytona
um so and my dad was kind of he wasn't a
biker but he was kind of peripherally
involved in that um so it's just kind of
like you're you're kind of like at the
point where it's like bikers I never had
a problem with bikers the only thing I
didn't like about growing up in Daytona
was all the spring breaker kid like the
Bros and stuff like The Fat Boys and
stuff that would come for spring they
would cause trouble yeah not bikers
never caused any trouble it never caused
any trouble motorcycle gangs come from a
background well first of all they're
exmilitary a lot of them ex cop or ex
con and um those institutions
breed Concepts like Brotherhood and
mutual respect that if you disrespect
some somebody they can hurt you the cops
are not involved in this it's almost
kind of like busho in a samurai code
it's it's very similar read m
you read mashi he spills it all out okay
it's exactly like that law and order as
you know it from with judges and cops
and not really there it's an honor-based
system not a legal based system so if
you're good to them they're going to be
good to you you tell the truth you're
going to be all right if you're fair
then you're gonna be all right you [__]
somebody over you're going to get [__]
over you lie they're going to [__] you
over just just be cool just like that
like I said I never had a problem um
with that because like I said we grew up
in the goth subculture which is similar
they're not as violent obviously but
it's the same principle yeah um
everybody knows Everybody Somebody [__]
somebody over there's going to be
repercussions to that my friend or our
friend big Tom he's a big old [__]
black guy all right he owns mannequins
which is a goth club he in downtown San
downtown San he asked us to help we do a
lot of work for him he asked us help
open he wanted me to manage the place I
was like Tom man cuz we've known him for
years all right [__] we met him at I
bar we met right like Tom man I'm
[__] I I can run a restaurant I can't
run a [__] bar man you know I good
thing I didn't get involved in that I
would have got canned okay
um in mannequins which is its main its
main thing is to be a goth club really
but it's supposedly horror them
supposedly horror thing but it's like a
well the warlocks were coming in there
along with other just jocks and
[__] and the and the warlocks were no
[__] trouble at all they figured it
out immediately how to hang out that
does not surprise me in this and they
just were part of the
[__] it was the jocks that we had
problems with yep always CU they don't
know how to behave nope but the warlocks
and and
uh I'm going to call law motorcycle
gangs know what a subculture is I have
literally never had a problem with
bikers in my whole entire life the only
problems that I've had were people with
people in nightclubs and stuff like that
were Frat Boys Bros type people yeah
that's who causes the problems not
bikers they don't know what a subculture
is they don't know how to behave around
a subculture they don't really
understand what cool
is they have a version of cool that
doesn't apply in an underground that we
don't even know what that right and they
their definition and they have a [__]
very Normy concept of
Justice you're [__] around with
people that are in organized crime
they'll kill you okay you'll end up in
the parking lot with a bullet in the
back your head all right and no one will
solve the murder and no one will know
what happened all right which is
something that's kind of alien to it to
to a to a mainstream jock boy they think
it's all it's about fists and don't want
to get locked up no the cops aren't
going to be there to save you all right
these These are these are this is the
mafia I got no problem with that I'm I
understand those dudes a lot better than
I understand [__]
[Laughter]
lawyers because those guys are dealing
with things that are tangible it's uh
the law advocate of if you come in some
place a public place and act an ass yeah
and people call you out on it perhaps
physically then I don't think anyone
should be punished for that because you
need to like [__] straighten
up and if that's the only way that
you're going to learn then I guess
you're GNA learn yeah Zach said B Zack
saying I think I'm going to Dayton in
March take me to the Oasis and then he
goes yeah the nail that sticks up gets
HED flat exactly
exactly no good Danny says no good deed
goes unpunished to be live by and then
Zach says bu Zack says you ever see the
box turtle on a post no he didn't get
there on his own hold on you got to read
that again you ever see a box turtle on
a post he didn't get there on his own
okay I'm not sure what he means by that
it's a metaphor okay go rest give me
another drink too while another drink
okay I'll make you another drink yeah I
mean probably most of you guys that um
have been here a long time know but
mannequins at one point
um I like going there I'm not saying
that but um they do try to cater to a
more alternative crowd but because it's
in downtown Sanford you get a lot of uh
random ass people wandering in that
don't really know what the [__] is going
on so it usually causes problems um it's
gotten a little better lately because
they do actually now uh have a cover
charge and they search everybody before
they go in I don't love that but you
know you got to do what you got to do
but prior to that um we me and Tom and
Our Friend Sophie who is uh a fan of the
show she's um she's from Michigan she's
in the chat sometimes but um she's
stayed with us several times and she was
actually staying with us at this point
and we took her to mannequin she' never
been and we had a situation where this
dude I don't know if he was drunk or on
drugs or something like that but he was
just like being really he wasn't being
like I don't know if I'd call it like
aggressive or anything like that but he
was just like me and Sophie were dancing
and it's just like he just kept hovering
you know what I mean and we were just
kind of like man this dude is just kind
of like he won't leave you know what I
mean he kept like getting closer and
closer and we're just like hey just like
back off you're kind of like in the
space and you're doing this and that and
he really didn't seem to get the memo I
guess and he just kept pushing and
pushing and pushing and finally like we
were getting so annoyed and then Tom was
just like kind of grabbed him by the
neck was like would you just please like
get off and he just like pulled uh him
over onto like the
floor and so at this point um Tom's kind
of doing that and like a couple of our
other friends including like this girl
named Anna that we know she kind of came
over it's like Tom you know just not not
worth it like let go of the dude or
whatever and so Tom like let's go of the
dude and then the dude comes right at me
even though I was just like standing
there doing nothing I was like not even
involved I was just like standing there
watching going hey look at that [__] you
know what I mean I was just standing
there and he came at me and tackled me
and knocked me to the floor and started
wailing on me like that and I'm was just
like what the [__] is happening and I
triy to put his eyes out and all this
other kind of stuff cuz I'm like what
the [__] is happening right now so
finally they like pulled the dude off
and kicked him out or whatever ever I
kind of left that strong all right that
way the flavors didn't get too [__] up
but yeah so it was the whole thing um
they had to carry the dude out and I
didn't really want to go back there for
a long time after that because I was
like look I just want to go out at night
and what you talking about dance that
that [__] that happened at Mar mannequin
that with that [__] dude I [__] that
dud that yeah and it's just kind of
like that's why we kind of prefer going
to Barbarella because because it's it's
more scen it's kind of in the middle of
nowhere you have to know where it is
yeah you can't just stumble across it
because it's in kind of in the middle of
it's in the warehouse District it's more
of a club scene everybody that goes
there comes from clubs everybody that
goes there knows where it is yeah um so
you can go there and do whatever and no
one is going to say anything to you no
one's going to [__] with you no one's
going to scantily clad women we know
everybody just everything just so we're
just kind of like it's much better like
I can relax there yeah everybody's a
scer they're not there to fight they're
there to [__] show off and dance they
just want to dance dance and show off
and [__] look cool nobody wants to
[__] with anybody no one wants to pick
up anybody it's not it's refreshing well
they got people picking each other up
but they're into it right but not in the
same way not in the same way not in the
same way it's all it's not the same way
as like mannequins you go there and it's
like I'm always kind of like afraid to
wear anything to reveal at manquin
because it's like you're going to have
some random jock [__] like
coming up and like touching my ass or
something like like [__] I don't know
you get the [__] off me I gota go I
gotta go ballistic right and it's just
kind of like cuz I don't z uh I'm just
dancing man I don't now buac sent me a
video earlier I think it was yesterday
you sent me a video of you on Instagram
of you on that damn bule SS TW 1200 xp12
SS you were riding with a whole gang of
guys on Harley bunch of Baggers and [__]
who was that was that was that a was
that a a club was that a motorcycle club
or was it just guys that you
knew that looks like the same situation
we have here uh in the Eustace area this
is [__] Harley-Davidson Heaven
they're just [__] everywhere they are
yeah Harley
Baggers we live kind of in a rural is
it's rural is I can get a Harley here
for next to nothing but it's going to be
a very vanilla a bagger with stereo and
all kinds of [__] I don't really want
that I want a
bobber maybe some bags on it but mostly
a bobber yeah buack says yeah bikers are
usually the best people anybody that's
into any kind of subculture like I said
we grew up in the goth SL Punk
subculture so it's like it's the same
kind of thing and it's weird because
people always tend to demonize people
that look like bikers or people that
look like gods or whatever but it's like
generally in my experience um people
that look like that are way nicer than
people that look like regular people
well it's cuz we fit in with them though
just saying
yeah I mean you know I know you're
outside or you're ass trouble yeah I
mean it's not that's not true across the
board but it's just like I feel like
people that are in a subculture people
that are bikers or Goths or whatever
you're wearing your um subculture you're
wearing your personality like on the
outside yeah um you're not hiding
anything so I kind of feel like the
problem with normies is that there could
be all kind of terrible [__] that they
are hiding underneath that
veneer and you don't know yeah you know
what I mean you don't know you don't
really know what you're getting yeah bu
Zack my friend [__] Chris rides up to
the Oasis all the time he's on one of
those I think it's like a one or twoy
old [__] Tri [__] rocket three
that [__] 200 horsepower [__]
monster it looks kind of like a [__]
some kind of weird it's not a cruiser
I'd call it a
[__] some kind of Street Fighter he
he rides up on that thing man that thing
is [__] badass forward controls and
everything I considering getting that
but it's not a good two up bike it's not
something I could put Jen on the back on
it looks too sweet to have a
[__] a co-writer plion on the back
I'm just going to ruin it she well no it
would
that that is a bikee that's supposed to
be red Solo there's some bikes look
great to for two up and and you know
what I mean I think that I think that
[__] Indians and Harley look good to
to up you know but uh yeah he pulls up
in there man and that [__]
packing too man he'll [__] go right
up in the [__] bar the [__] butt
of his [__] pistol sticking out of
his [__]
jeans he was [__] carrying that damn
[__] Sig there a Sig three three 65
that's what it was it was also in there
with a [__] Smith [__] EZ one
time Oscar says you guys got to get on
that three-way with the bar chick you
just
showed yeah she wants a [__]
threesome so bad she [__] loves me
and she loves jet she Lo like I said the
first time I met her she seemed all
about it and she's just she's
boobalicious
she's our age she's cute I like her yeah
she's our age she lives here her dad
lives across the street yeah she only
lives like across the street from her
dad Liv which we didn't know when he
first started going there it's not
across from the house this is across the
street from the uh from from from the
complex from yeah like yeah we live in
like a um like a it's not it's not a
gated community because it's not gated
it was built to be gated but it isn't G
but not gated yet but she lives in the
farm across from the farm across the
street the neighborhood yeah she lives
with her dad it was like right that we
could walk to her house pretty much yeah
her dad's uh kind of infirm
she's probably 51 52 well same age as me
yeah same as you and she's old biker
chick and she just [__] loves Mo she
got to know me she just thought I was
[__] great I was always showing her
pictures of you and she go oh she's hot
look at this [__] look at her she's one
of the ones that's kind of like uh she's
very boob cetric when we were all
hanging out me you and and Melissa and
her boyfriend who had he had a slick
[__] Harley he did have he he fast he
let me ride it it was [__] quick but
he had the he had the shift [__]
lever adjusted too low I couldn't get my
boot underneath and I was going to have
to [__] reach way out the side and
[__]
upshift but uh we were there that night
and she goes man your friends are so
[__] cool and she goes and she goes
and I love your wife we got to get
together she I love your wife we got to
get together she is so [__] beautiful
she's so cool a yeah she she thought you
were great I am pretty cool yeah she
thought you're great if I do say so
myself yeah my mom told me I was cool
yeah that's not true my mom never told
me that I got I I got pictures of her
I'd be [__] sitting there [__]
drinking and she's in the background
dancing I'm [__] videotaping showed
you that yet she's [__] hilarious I
don't think so she's [__] hilarious I
don't think so
yeah she's been wanting to meet you
though she's like when you going to
bring her down here cuz she I've met her
before yeah she keeps wanting you to
come down there well if just let me know
when you're down there cuz I got a drive
down I'm going to show you I'm going to
show you the last time I went I really
haven't been going recently either yeah
you just you know you didn't go there
today I haven't been there in weeks yeah
last time that I went down there was
when our friend like I said Melissa and
her boyfriend yeah they were going to
bik Tober fast yeah and they stopped
there like on the way cuz they live in
Orlando so they stopped there on the way
and they're like hey you you guys want
to come down so Tom went down on his
bike and I drove down on the car and
then we hung out with him cuz I had seen
Melissa in forever and I love her but
you know
okay here here's here's one little video
of her yeah she's putting on a [__]
show she seems like a fun girl yeah
she's funny I'm gonna say she's funny
she does seem fun
yeah all right let me see I got some
other [__] crazy ones
over yeah I don't know if I read that
but uh buack said yeah bikers are
usually the best people people like I
said anybody that's into like
subcultures are
usually pretty good
people despite
what Normie culture might think of
them I imagine she probably gets really
good tips yeah yeah with that brother
well actually she asked if she asked me
if you wanted to work
there and [__] I was saying well what
kind of money it was but the thing is
you were making more money than that I
mean I don't know I thought about being
a bartender back in the old
days I don't know if I'd be super good
at it
though you have to flash your tits at
that point that's what I well which
we've done that [__] but yeah but in the
sense that it's a very public facing and
it's like most people just get on my
nerves and it's just kind of like look
I've I've worked in retail I've worked
in public fa and I don't like it I don't
like having to like deal with people
they annoy yeah those dudes there you
probably wouldn't like it that's what I
mean it would probably just like annoy
me cuz there's the biker is not a
problem the problem is there is just
like the [__] okay this is is this
the one this the one where she's behind
me [__] Hamming it up yeah okay okay
okay okay [__] I don't know okay okay
hold well I don't know I haven't hold
I'm show yeah this is it I haven't seen
this one this one's funny he makes all
kind of videos of them telling
me it's me drinking there drinking and
I'm [__] doing and all of a sudden
she's [__] yelling and screaming so I
put her in the back of the corner and
she's back there
dancing she's back there dancing trying
to pull her titties
out okay yeah let's see if I can show it
again what song is that it's [__]
from James
Bond that's what I had on the Jew box oh
that's right I was [__] je I was
[__] uh DJing you were a DJ I was
DJing I see that
yeah she's super cute though I like her
yeah you'd like her I like her she's
funny and she does live nearby super
Southern super Southern I mean I'm
Southern too but she's redneck though
there's a difference not a not but no
she knows all about you [__] whenever
I go up there she's asking and [__]
[__] we're just Tom is always telling
everybody about me yeah
yeah I don't even know like all the
stuff that he's telling about me she
knows she knows you're a writer she
knows about the show she knows about
everything
interesting murder Hornet said Hunter
Thompson Hunter EST yeah yeah yeah got
his ass beat by the Hell's Angels
writing his book about them yeah that's
right that's right he
did H yeah Danny ring said dealing with
drunk customers would suck yeah when I
was younger um because I was really into
the whole club culture and everything
like that I said you know what maybe I
should be a bartender so I thought about
going to when I went to the meeting for
bartender school and everything like
that but I was just kind of like one it
was super expensive and two I was just
kind of like wait do I really want to
deal with it's like I don't even really
like dealing with sober people would I
really like to deal with drunk people on
a regular basis probably not probably
not I don't like dealing with anybody on
a regular basis drunk or superber so I
don't know how that would have worked
out I don't know how people do it I
admire people that do it
but just
saying yeah said I thought you couldn't
carry firearms in places where they
serve alcohol no you can't but they're
going to do it anyway I mean technically
it's not allowed they're going to do it
anyway but a lot of people do yeah in
rural Florida now especially now that
it's open carry well it's not open carry
yeah it's constitutional carry you
cannot carry openly in other words you
can't have a pistol strapped to you or
you can't walk around with a rifle in
public but you can carry concealed
without a license
as long as you can legally own a gun you
can carry
it um as long as it's
not
open uh which that's fine that it's
always been that way traditionally in
the United States every every person
women and everything should be able to
defend themselves the cops are not
really here to defend you they'll try to
help but especially in rural areas the
response to time is too long it could be
half hour 45
minutes so really you I don't carry one
but I'm not a kind of guy that gets
troubled I've never really been that way
been a guy that been troubled that could
get troubled
but
um everyone should have the right to
carry [__] some [__] to defend
themselves with cops can't really help
you this is not England or some some
place in Europe where you have a high
population density and the cops are
right there and people follow rules
America set on Expert they don't follow
any rules here you had to watch yourself
now that doesn't mean that it's
dangerous everywhere which I think maybe
some foreigners might get some
foreigners might it's not dangerous in
most places it's not that dangerous yeah
foreigners get a weird view you know CU
we have I walked around by myself yeah
all the time all the time I used to go
to clubs by myself all the time before
me and you got together after I got
divorced yeah and I was not I didn't
usually encounter any problems if I did
I probably would have stepped on the
dude's neck and then cut his gut open
and taken all his intentions out okay
you got to put things in contest
context it's more D in in more rural
areas there isn't going to be police Ser
prompt Police
Service um you kind of have to watch
yourself okay uh although it's mostly
quiet peaceful but it is not as quiet as
it was in the old west people are like
well man this ain't the wild west no
it's much worse than the wild west well
the wild west there wasn't as many
people there weren't as very many people
it was a lot more spread out it was a
lot more spread out and then something
like the shootout at the okay Corral
which went down in West history as being
like the biggest thing in the world that
happens now if that were to happen today
it wouldn't even be noticed talk about
no we even talk about it it's much worse
than well that's what's funny about it
is that people still talk about it
because it
was
yeah now it's like that happened now
like it wouldn't even make the news
probably they're just like yeah this
happened again big deal PE again okay so
um if you're a European or you're
British and you like [__] like guns
there's a lot of [__] British guys
that I know that like guns you can come
to United stat you to have a [__]
good time and it's and it's safe you can
go out and
shoot especially in a more rural area in
a friendly State somewhere in the South
you'd have a good time uh I do not
recommend going into uh certain [__]
uh urban areas like uh Chicago no has a
[__] war zone I got a listener here
he's moving here [__] to uh to to
Florida now that he visited he's like
yeah he's from Chicago he's like yeah
man I'm moving down [__] and he says
he he loved it here it's just a
different culture and I've lived all
over the United States I've lived all
over the
world
Brazil [__] been to
Germany uh [__] lived in Korea lived
in Egypt I have all kinds of family
members that lived all throughout the
Middle East I got uncles and aunts that
live in [__] um
uh UAE United Arab Emirates and uh
what's the other
one
Dubai two of my uncles were Task Force
160 Special Operations Aviation they're
[__] Commandos they're now
professional uh helicopter pilots and
bodyguards for very important shakes and
[__] okay of the Middle East they're
great guys and they are [__] jacked
they're in their 50s and they're they're
on gear and all kinds of stuff and they
fly private helicopters and carry pdws
or little [__] submachine guns and
their bodyguards and uh so they do that
in the Middle East there's all kinds of
cool [__] out there my family is [__]
has been involved in government and
[__] special operations for going
back Generations my mother was state
department and she did [__] inside the
state department that was [__]
weird um my grandfather on my mother's
side
was a defense contractor for [__]
McDonald
Douglas [__] um also General atomics
he worked on the
[__] [__] what was that the
[__] what was it what was the name of
that [__] project where they had the
damn atomic bombs to launch the [__]
rocket he did that [__] forgot what the
name of that was I used to remember but
but I'm drunk and um
Grumman my granddad built the [__]
did the uh fuel injection system in the
F14 Tomcat did the [__] stage
separation system inside the [__]
Saturn 5 rocket to go to the moon and
all that [__] so my family especially on
my mother's side was deeply involved in
all this
[__] there there's a lot of [__] cool
[__] out there um I forgot where I was
going for this but drinking I don't know
don't look at me I was in the bathroom
yeah it doesn't matter doesn't matter
Jeffy said as security I have to deal
with drunk G man many can be real
[__] when sober never mind with a few
drinks last August we had a deal with
this Shady dude bringing in a 9mm into
our bar turns out he had a wrap sheet a
mile long yeah our bar has a zero
tolerance for guns I mean
I understand in that role who has a zero
tal for against the bar that he works at
oh yeah well yeah most bars like I yeah
and and I can see that like alcohol and
guns do not mix it depends on the
clientele at mannequins that's a younger
clientele and my uh my boy Tom big Tom
he's got security out there and they're
doing [__] metal detectors to make
sure no guns go in there because they
got some young [__] and they're
too [__] stupid to have guns okay uh
in a place like Oasis it's not quite as
a big deal that's an older
crowd and a lot of those guys are
ex-military and they're not carrying the
gun because there's problems inside the
bar they just carry that [__] [__]
that's just on general purpose just cuz
just cuz and they they got really
expensive
motorcycles and some of them are in
organizations you know what I mean and
they're just hopefully they wouldn't
blow up their whole life yeah just by
shooting somebody over a drunken alter
yeah that's not what they're doing
that's not what they're doing they're
afraid of being attacked by Outsiders
and stuff and and probably although the
Oasis I don't really see that happening
yeah well it's not guys
inside they're afraid that they're in
the bar the bike's out front some kind
of enemy sees the
motorcycle and they stop and go in and
gun the Dude down that's what they're
afraid of they're not really afraid of
the other guys in the bar they're afraid
of being spoted
but the thing is is that there's also a
that may not be all of it a lot of it
might be the swag of it well and if
you're that afraid of people finding you
like what have you done in your past
life they're doing criminal [__] because
like I said yeah I'm Not Afraid
anybody's goingon to well I'm afraid of
like just random dudes doing [__] to me
because that's how they do but it's just
like I haven't done anything criminal my
life that anyone's going to take revenge
for yeah so I'm not worried about that I
think I think there's a big element of
Swag yeah I I kind of think that's what
it is yeah because honestly like I said
I don't see myself look I've I've never
um you know uh given testimony yeah in a
trial against a serial killer for
example uh I've never done anything like
that or against a mobster or something
so it's like I no one's coming after me
for that like I said it could be that
there's some random serial killer that's
into to my kind of old ass hey I'm
really into Old goth chicks and I'm a
serial killer and I'm just going to like
do this like I can see that but other
than that I don't really
fear anyone yeah I'm not I don't worry
about when I go in there either I don't
care I've been there I've been there a
few times and it's it doesn't bother me
I'm not bother the music is the thing
that bothers yeah it's country western
but I'll be in there and there'll be two
or three of them I'll be talking to them
all and they might packing but it
doesn't I don't even care about it cuz I
know they're all X military and [__]
[__] couple decades ago we'd be be in
the back of a [__] deuce and a half
truck all of us with [__] loaded M16s
and [__] pointing guns at each other by
accident just because you can't stand
anywhere without having a gun pointed at
you so I I don't care about it you know
what I mean it's just that that that's
their that's their thing and that's
their thing I don't
care I got my own guns right here you
know what I'm talking about nobody's
fing for me
I'll just [__] well like I said no
one's looking for me no one's looking
for me I don't really care well like I
said I'm a girl but like you know I'm
old so I kind of feel like I'm not the
Target demographic for but I'm not
saying that doesn't happen because it
does so Hornet said I think every woman
should uh train to use a firearm and
carry absolutely um yeah I mean maybe in
the United States
absolutely maybe you should I'm going to
take her I'm going to train her I
haven't really trained her yet I've been
[__] laxed about I'm going to take
her out to the range and train
just in case anybody comes in here I'm
not here so you're you can know how to
pick something up and know what it's
like I would rather kill a
dude with my bare hands that ain't gonna
happen I would rather kill a dude with
my bare hands I think I would get more a
lot a lot more satisfaction from that a
lot more
satisfaction I'm just
saying uh gther says Hey gther Hammer
has joined the chat
uh really interesting to hear Tom's
opinion on this yeah it's just kind of
like I don't know I'm
not I don't love it I don't love it that
people are like carrying guns around in
public places but it doesn't bother me
depending on what the clientele is you
know what I mean I've been in the Oasis
I know a lot of them are carrying guns
it doesn't bother me there because
they're older so I kind of feel like
it's
not it's not going to be a situation
where people are going to like pop off
and
get all upset about stuff and like I
said the only time that I've ever been
there is just like afternoons it's not
I've never been there at night um from
what I've heard it's probably not a good
idea to go there at night I don't know
but the only times I've ever been there
is like in the afternoon you know and it
seems pretty chill at that time but you
know I watch and write about enough True
Crime though to know that you have to
like watch your [__] ass like all the
time so you know I'm old but I still
watch my [__]
ass like I said I would
enjoy somebody that tried to like do
something I would
enjoy pulling their intestines out I
would enjoy that not
saying
um Jeffy art said I recall a story where
a med student in Baltimore killed an
intruder with a katana
that wouldn't surprise me people use
whatever they have to defend themselves
hey
man that's you got Katana is that's a
good weapon yeah but you know we have to
be realistic the
average man is three times stronger than
the average
woman and faster and the average guy who
attacks a woman in her home is not the
average guy he's a little bit above
average that's why the [__] kill
ratio is so
high the best option for any female to
defend herself is a
firearm now in other countries they may
not allow
them which I think is insane although
they think we're insane for having them
we'll have something at least yeah um
they depend on police which is same as
depend depending on you're a man and
they expect you to depend on other men
to protect you I I don't understand that
get a knife cut that bit
the American philosophy is that
every
citizen defends himself every citizan is
like a policeman although you have to
[__] do things within the confines of
the law so you have to know what your
local laws
are um police are not overlords they're
just other
citizens their job is to [__] enforce
laws or to keep the peace really a
originally in America was to keep the
peace law enforcement was not any was
not a thing that started more in the 70s
and the 80s where they enforcing laws on
people that's like something a
dictatorship does it's not a good I like
peace officers better where everybody
does their own thing if there's a
trouble the peacekeepers come in and
sort the [__] out you know what I'm
talking about make sure they're not
fighting that's really the way it should
be but the Empire has grown into
something it was never intended to be
it's trying to become a totalitarian
state and it's trying to become very
technologically based in other words
like a technocracy very much the Chinese
model of [__] total control because
they know their [__] they want to
know what your internet activities are
and they're trying to shut you down that
way it ain't going to work I'm in big
trouble man yeah it ain't going to work
these are the Mad dreams of dictators
the same as the Nazis they're like
that
um it it it'll come around cuz people
aren't going to stand for the [__] s
like had his sneeze I believe in a free
and open system and human
rights
damn gther says hey what's up grandr is
here yeah yeah what's up Grand sorry I
was
sneezing um yeah gramp is his uh high
school friend of mine he's a retired cop
now but we came we actually went to
drama school together yeah Zach says do
you guys watch police crime
interrogation videos I
do um I'm a big fan of I don't know if
fan is the right word but I really like
True Crime [__] I've written three books
of True Crime about unsolved
murders and I had I maintain a Blog
about unsolved murders where I post
something every day about unsolved
murders so I'm kind of like immersed in
unsolved murder [__] so I do kind of
like watch a lot of True Crime it
bothers
Tom after a while
um but I don't know I watch it a lot
yeah I don't know what it is but Granda
just talking about my opinions on
[__] he goes through
there we went to school together he was
a cop for 27 years he retired he said he
tried to save everybody but he couldn't
well you can't you can't um the citizens
have to be able to help themselves yeah
you should call the cops for backup all
that [__] that and other people can help
too but I get it I get it right
everybody has to
[__] pull
together legal
citizens who are not
[__] marked for bad
behavior have the constitutional right
to defend themselves with Firearms they
can also defend the state with Firearms
they can also help law enforcement if
they have to [__] um now I also
believe that the dudes that do this
shouldn't be total rookies you really
should [__] go through some training
and stuff well hopefully
now it's hard to say you're in a
situation well we can't give you this
gun because you're not trained you got
to go through this training
first in some ways I'm kind of I'm kind
I kind of like that in other ways I
don't you shouldn't really stand in the
way of somebody defending themselves cuz
somebody are old women you know what I
mean and old woman can't go through the
[__] training too well you know like
not enough training like her you can't
hold her to the same standards as a law
enforcement agent she just needs to be
able to pick up something on the side of
the bed at night [__] pull a trigger
at somebody coming at her through a
window you know what I mean well right
it's there should be two different there
should be a bunch of different stands
for how old these people are whatever
what are we expecting out of this
particular person you know at the end of
the
training but I've been in situations
just where [__] just accidents on the
road and I've just [__] jumped off
the bike going out and start helping
[__] cops putting tourniquet on
people and doing [__] like that they
even ask who I was but just because I'm
exmilitary I know how to do that kind of
[__] they didn't even question
it they're like okay okay yeah yeah he's
helping he's helping so it's right yeah
I'm helping [__] other dudes that got
wiped out on
motorcycles and uh because you know you
can ask Grand if a guy if a civilian
jumps forth and he just the body
language and the skills they don't they
just let [__] happen well I would hope
so yeah cuz they know well he must know
what he's doing he knows he's doing well
and everyone is kind of like well we're
trying to help the vi trying to help
this dude that got [__] wiped out hit
hit by car or whatever yeah and if
someone looks like they're doing
something good then we're not what I was
talking about is a guy was on a
Harley-Davidson that [__] got hit in
the middle of an intersection and then
him and the bike [__] went [__]
crazy and went into the damn bushes this
is over there near where the DMV was uh
I I forgot where it was [__] near
That Pizza Place a long time ago that
think that's before me and you were a
thing which one by the Starbucks and the
burger it was uh down
434 you keep going and going and going
and going and going and then that's
where the DMV is where you get where you
okay I think where you get your driver's
licenses yeah yeah yeah I know what
you're talking about I was on my way
back and
[__] saw a guy who got wiped out he
was on a Harley I'm treating him for
[__] head injury and Trauma and
[__] trying to fix his trying to get
his been through the same through the
same thing the cops showed up and I'm
[__] helping the cops and they're
calling [__] paramedics and stuff
they thought I was with him I wasn't
with him I just came up on the scene
well yeah and they got him out of there
well you did the right thing you just
like I had [__] some combat Lifesaver
training from the Army yeah but didn't
even question what I was doing yeah well
in you know in the best circumstances
they shouldn't because you're helping
right yeah so it's like you would like
to think like if somebody was for
example a nurse or a doctor or something
like that they're like I'm just going to
jump out and help this person and it's
just kind of like if somebody was like
hey what are you doing that would be
[__] he had a bad head injury he was
sitting there just growling like an
animal and trying to fight did you ever
figure out what happened to him no they
took him away I don't know what happened
oh and I was like uh look I don't know
the guy says you don't know the guy I
says no I don't know him what are you
going to do with this bike I no we're
going to pick the bike up I says okay
all right all right yeah it was an old
bagger BG he was in his
50s had a little bitty brain case
[__] helmet on it wasn't a full face
helmet it [__] him up that's why I saw
that [__] you better have a full-f face
helmet full face helmet makes a big
difference seriously if you didn't wear
all the [__] I wear full when you wear
when you go out in your motorcycle I
would be a lot more worried about you
than I already am and dude was trying to
fight he was [__] twice my
size big
dude but that's cool that you try to
like help him I don't I wonder what
happened to that dude I don't know he's
taking away he he'd have survived he
survived yeah yeah he survived yeah I
was worse than
that yeah you got real [__] up yeah
you were in a coma yeah I was in a coma
he was not in a coma for how long were
you r a coma 2 days I thought it was
longer than that no it was only two days
yeah okay so it was two days but I was
in and out of it for about a week you
know what I mean but two days come and
then like in and out cuz your helmet
came off yeah it came off it wasn't
strapped just had the helmet
on and being a
dick I'm just running up the street to
go turn some videos in yeah wear your
helmet you guys yeah that's what
happens
gther says when things are dire cops
will take all the help they can get yeah
which like I said I hope they do I've
seen some of those [__] there's a
really good Channel on YouTube called uh
police activity which is police body cam
stuff and uh man you can see what cops
actually go through some of the [__]
weird ass decisions they have to make
[__] psychos that just run at them
with knives and
[__] although it's pretty fair they do
have some where the cop was definitely
wrong for shooting a dude that was doing
nothing
but it's
mostly totally understandable what
happens all this stuff about oh well
they're just going out hunting people no
no they're mostly following procedure
from what I saw and uh difficult
difficult decisions well in a lot of
situations you don't really know yeah
what to do yeah you know I can think of
out of those hundreds of videos there
was only like one or two where it was
like oh no they were [__] up for doing
that should have never shot that dude he
was surrendering you know [__] that
kind of [__] you know what I mean but uh
they're disciplined of course and
another things that you see is like
where One Cop is doing the right thing
and the other cop isn't helping I was
like why isn't the partner doing
anything you know what I mean just
stupid all right so it's in the Army we
used to have what's called a after
action review and they would review [__]
of what happened during some kind of
attack that fake attack that we did or
what whatever and [__] I would every
time I see those videos I I would
imagine what the a ARS are like the
after Action reviews and most of the
time most of the cops do well sometimes
some of the cops do [__] up stupid
[__] and um you look at the cop and
you're like well of course how the hell
did that person end up on a force you
know I mean you look at him there's
nothing cop like about him you know out
of shape
or just whatever you know I don't want
to get too personal you know just like
put on there for political
reasons
um or it's some girl who's scared to get
involved and like the partner's getting
[__] just shot the [__] up and the
girl's just sitting there screaming and
you're like you got a gun help him but
you know just you know I don't want to
say it's sexist they got some women that
can deliver but in that particular case
that I'm thinking of that chick didn't
belong on a force
um sometimes you see guys that just
don't belong on a [__] Force they're
just too [__] you have a job
description that entails you having a
firearm and you having power over other
people um partner there's always going
to be a small percentage of people that
are going to be drawn to that for the
wrong reasons yeah yeah yeah um you know
so we're going to say there have been
like uh you know a small percentage
of people yeah that have been like cops
that pulled women over and raped them
like [__] like that so that has happened
look I'm not prejudiced
okay I'm a 5 foot6 190lb guy I would
didn't always weigh [__] 190 lbs a
lot of times it was 150 lbs I would
never recommend a 5 foot6 150 lb man be
a [__] cop the ultimate cop's [__]
6'3 weighs 200 something [__] pounds
all right he's a big ass bouncer that's
what you want as a cop it's not
necessarily what you want as a Commando
though you know what I mean like in the
Army Rangers all right because it's very
Firearms oriented very [__] stealth
about hiding and being [__] small and
getting into some [__] nooks and
crannies and jumping out like a
bushwhacker and murdering somebody
because Warfare is about murder really
that's what it is all right law
enforcement is not like
that from what I've seen scene and being
a smaller guy you want a big strong
[__] well depending on what you
want from that dude yeah well no you're
going to have to deal with [__] thugs
right but for that but I'm just saying
for you know detectives and stuff like
that that's kind of I'm talking about a
line cop that's what I meant I'm talking
about a line cop you want a big [__]
Burly [__] that's like a that
can beat the [__] out of an average dude
that's what you really want uh they need
to [__] emphas emphasis on that now
other things like you said detectives
and undercover people yeah you need
actors people that can [__]
infiltrate you know I me Fe people they
can like solve Mysteries sex ops yeah
right well that's that's a different job
I'm talking about a lion cop same thing
with [__] firemen all right somebody
who [__] bust in a door bust down
doors in the middle of a fire and pull
people out and carry people over the
shoulders I want big [__] I
don't want 5 foot five 5 foot6
[__] doing that and that's the
size I I am I don't want to be saved by
a dude my size I want to be [__]
like [__] a foot taller than me can
run through a damn wall all right and
want three of them I mean I would hope
that somebody could pick up my fat ass
yeah yeah you want big [__]
doing that [__] so I don't I don't I
don't weigh that much I'm just right
okay I just I'm ganther says most of the
cops I worked with were topnotch but not
all you want smart cops who can talk to
people yeah it's another thing but bring
the heat when needed
exactly and there's not a lot of people
that have both of those in equal measure
I
feel maybe I'm wrong about that maybe
I'm wrong about that might need another
drink okay at this
stage Tammy blessed me for sneezing back
then I don't know what that was all
about
yeah I can't imagine like I
said I watch a lot of True Crime stuff
and Tom doesn't like it but I watch it
um I've been watching Cold Case Files on
Netflix I love that [__] show I don't
know why but it just makes him
mad but I don't know to me it's
fascinating because yes a person died
that is horrible but I want that [__] to
be solved you know what I mean I'm like
I'm one of those people I want that
[__] mystery to be like figured out
we you have to figure out who [__]
did this who did this you know what I
mean even it's like [__] 40 years
later I still want to know I still want
to figure it out so I like that show
because that
show is predicated on the entire premise
that it's like here's this crime that
happened back in the [__] 70s or 80s
or whatever and then 40 [__] years
later somebody solved it like we figured
out even if the dude was dead or even he
was already in prison or or something
like that at least we [__] figured
out who did it you know what I mean and
it's like that's very satisfying for me
it's very
satisfying
um Sebastian said how about Maniac Cop
we should probably do I forgot about
that movie one of these days yeah um a a
review of all of the Maniac Cop movies
yeah I forgot I like I like the Maniac
Cop movies I do we should probably do
that
Zach says uh that's the kind of crime
stuff I watch I watch all kinds of crime
stuff um I like anything to do with true
crime or Cults or anything like that
um I you know write
about my whole thing is I have a whole
three
volume you know I I have three volumes
of books about unsolved
murders so I'm kind of used to [__] that
like not resolved but I think maybe
that's kind of why I watch Cold Case
Files because it's like well at least I
know that this one's going to be figured
out even though it takes several decades
to be figured out at least some
someone's going to figure out who
[__] did this you know what I mean
because it kind of bums me out that I
write about stuff all the time
that they never figured out who did it
they still haven't figured out who did
it although I will say that um um a lot
of the cases that I wrote about in my
books
um they have kept working on them to
their credit um so a lot of you know at
least I it's interesting because I try
to keep up on like a lot of the um cases
that I wrote about in my books I try to
keep up on the stuff for my blog I have
a Blog called crime in Memorial and I
post like stuff about new unsolved
crimes like every day and I try to keep
up with a lot of the cases that I talked
about in my original books you know the
faceless villain
series and a lot of the you know victims
in there that were not
identified they have identified them
like as of now which is really cool I I
like that they kind of kept up on it you
know what I mean so a lot of them like
they still don't know who killed the
people but they at least know who the
people are so I do try to keep up with
all of that stuff you know what I mean
it's like I'm not 100% at it but you
know I do try to keep up with it I do
try to keep up with
um Jeffy said there's several fresh
cases in Canada that are unsolved it's
frustrating that the obvious suspects
never get investigated Canada must be
murder or Paradise um one thing that
I've noticed about Canada I don't you
know I've written a lot about I wrote
about um and we did a whole show about
Len and onario which was kind of like
murder capital of the world for a little
while but um and there was actually a
case that I watched on Cold Case Files
last
night about a woman that disappeared
from there and they didn't find her
until much later she was actually in
California and they figured out who
killed her but you know what I mean um
there the dude had killed like another
person but they still don't know who
that other victim is
she Jen's written a bunch of uh crime
books
non-fictions might want to check those
out one of these days we've done shows
on it too there a lot of [__] here you
did she did how many you done you done
like [__] well it's a
Trilogy yeah yeah three of them it's
called The Faceless villain faceless
villain unsolved murders the first one
is um you know like pre1 1950 you can
get it all off Amazon the second one I
think is 1950 to 1969 and then the third
one is like
19 wait a minute 79 to 89 or yeah 99 I
can't remember but yeah so there's it's
like a
Trilogy so I wrote about unsolved crimes
but I still maintain a Blog too called
crime IM
memorial.com that I wrote about a lot of
the crimes on there and I also kind of
like try to keep updated on if um if any
of the [__] is solved you know what I
mean we did a thing at horror con here
at [__]
Orlando and [__] I sold all of her
books there [__] she bought how many
books did we buy I don't know a lot and
in hard copy about a 100 well my true
crime and my horror novels still cuz I
read horror novel yeah over a period of
about three days I sold every one of
those [__] we had so much fun at that
at that place I don't those haven't
started back up recently have they are
they started back up at Horicon
they did one last year yeah how did how
was the turnout um I'm not real sure
actually we didn't get invited well I
think that they're kind of minimal
minimizing the book thing okay all right
you know so we would have to pay to go
back next time probably you'd have to
pay to get your own right yeah yeah I
don't want to pay no we're going to pay
like when we went we actually didn't
they paid for us to go they paid for us
to go they did everything yeah so the
thing is though is that we made money on
that but we wouldn't have made money had
we had to pay no absolutely not we
actually do more on online sales but
it's fun to do [__] [__] in real life
you know what I mean you're there yeah
it's nice to like meet people fua was
there yeah yeah I was sitting there
hanging out with that [__] blue-eyed
[__] actress Shick what was her name
again [__]
uh the one from [__] yeah the one
that was in they live and the one was
they was in L live and what was that
I'll think of it in a second yeah I
forgot that chick's name yeah I got
pictures of us with her
um Tom savini was there he's always at
those yeah he's always there I met him
before yeah he seems like a seems
Cassandra Peterson was there I'm a huge
fan of like Tom savini by the way so
elvir was there [__] yeah it was it's
a good show it was it was cool yeah I
had a good time I always like going to
horror conventions but like I said I'm
only going to go because they're
expensive we only went because they paid
for us to go yeah they're like hey we
bought a table
you know you can put your books on it we
bought
your uh you know weigh in so I I didn't
have to pay we from Hellraiser
one he she was in Hellraiser wasn't she
oh right yeah yeah yeah oh [__] was her
name she had the [__] bright blue
eyes she wasn't in Hellraiser I thought
it was in Hellraiser no she was in they
live I told you she was in Hellraiser
too I think oh maybe she was
in no she wasn't Hellraiser one
absolutely not is that the one where uh
she where that dude's the blood hit and
the dude came back to life start yeah
but she yeah she was in that yeah but I
know you're talking about and she was
not in Hell Riser
one not at
all I don't know what you're thinking
about but it's not when the guys was
pulling his [__] skin off his face
yeah I know yeah she was it's Hellraiser
no she wasn't in that she wasn't in the
first Hellraiser from Foster yeah fost
that's right Jeff Foster in hellis was
not in hell rais what movie was that I
was thinking of that she was in she was
in they
live yeah that was one of them then
there was another one she was in lots of
movies she was in
lot was not one of them okay I don't
know if she was in one of the sequels
but she for sure was not in the first H
Foster I saw her she was walking right
towards me picture I didn't expect her I
was like man it'ser of Tom and bigone
yeah I was [__] hugging on her and
[__] like that [__] she
sit and I was like man I said I
recognize you anywhere say you're
looking great and she's like thank you
Jen's down there on the [__] um
sitting at the uh yeah thank you Jeffrey
said Meg Foster wasn't in Hellraiser
yeah she wasn't inaz absolutely not
absolutely not she was in something like
Hellraiser it was in Hellraiser I don't
remember what movie it was that I'm
remembering her from I told you she was
in they live yeah but I thought I
thought she was in another one too I
mean she was in other [__] too but she
was absolutely not H
raiser I asked her I said I said M come
get a drink with us and she's like okay
yeah cuz we had a whole bunch of [__]
booze and said no no I we brought a
bunch of Bo brought buch come on we had
a bag full say you want a drink little
yeah yeah yeah airplane yeah minis yeah
not all these airplane Min want drink
holy [__] man we came prepared and she's
like yeah yeah yeah so we were GNA walk
back there me and Jen and [__] b f
walk back there and she goes oh no no I
can't says you can't goes no I got to go
[__] do the signings I go talk talk
talk to people downstairs because they
they they pimp them out they go
downstairs they had they to [__] make
money to talk to this and she and she
want to get loaded before she had to
work but I could tell I could tell I
could tell Meg [__] was into the
drink she's like yeah yeah was drink but
the timing was wrong but she she said
yeah and I like come on let's go get
something drink she see here's the thing
I can't I can't you get paid to go to
one of those yeah which we did we got
our um we got both of our uh you know
entry fees paid we got all that stuff
paid so we go there and it's like but
they expect you to be on a certain
amount of panels yeah panels so we had
to do a panel about I remember what all
the panels were I did a women in horror
panel that was fun um I did a David
Lynch panel because she knew that I was
a big David Lynch fan uh so we did that
um we did the Friday night night getting
drunk whatever panel we were the head of
that um so we did that yeah we were
great on panels it was [__] fun yeah
we had to do a bunch of panels like over
the weekend because that was like the
you know that that was the they paid for
you to get in so like so you're just
kind of like you have to do all these
panels yeah we were all we were the
locals yeah we were in the local scene
for
Orlando and uh we did well man [__]
we sold alling books yeah we had a great
time they're saying that I'm confusing
Meg Foster with Carrie Higgins no yeah
yeah yeah CLA Higgins Higgins she was in
Hellraiser one yeah I'm not though I
just kind of thought that she was in
that movie she was absolutely not movie
was she in I thought she was in one of
those
movies I'm not real sure like what movie
you're think think of a different movie
that she was in because it's like look
I'm a big CAD Barker fan yeah I thought
it was a c bker movie no I've seen well
I've seen um Hellraiser multiple times
she is not in that movie yeah she's not
in that movie I don't know like maybe
she was in one of the later sequels
because I haven't seen those but I don't
think
so it was absolutely not the first I can
go look I can go look and see what M
Foster was in yeah you go you go figure
that
out it's the century she was in her 60s
and she still looks great she looked
cute
I thought recogn she just walked by the
table yeah and she was instantly
recognizable yeah instantly recognizable
yeah and and quite cool skinny real
skinny and I was like oh my God it's me
Foster yeah yeah and like you know and
she was ready to party sh like mik
Foster so it's like so I got a picture
of like her and Tom because I was like
holy [__] I was like I was so excited
and it's just like
but you know I I don't know man I don't
know I know I know her from they live
and like well like from some other
movies I know she was in some other Stu
Masters of the Universe yeah yeah yeah
remember that Leviathan Blind Fury oh
Leviathan was good too what movie was I
thinking of I'm not really sure
Tom let's figure it out together I'm
looking at all the movies she was in
let's figure out there was something
that was kind of like hell Reser I was
thinking of but it's absolutely not
Razer not the first one no way I've seen
that multiple times read the book I'm
looking at all her
[__] Jeffy art said I have the faceless
villain on Audible it's a good list
highly recommended Jeffy arton yeah yeah
yeah yeah I feel like I should maybe do
an update because like I said a lot of
the well not a lot but some of the cases
from that I talked about in those books
have been
solved or at least some of the like um
victims have if you know who we're
talking about that's who we're talking
about what that's M Foster that's me
that's J with my boobies yeah with boobs
her yeah my wallpaper is Jen and her
boobs isn't that funny it's awesome I'm
proud
of um now that was Meg Foster back in
the day I thought she was in [__]
Hellraiser but she's not okay yeah yeah
that's Claire Higgins she was a brid
actor um mag Foster is
American yeah at the time we s she
looked more like
that yeah but like I said she walked by
the table yeah and I was just kind of
like super bright super bright ice I was
super excited super bright ice blue
eyes cuz you know yeah I'm toring like
that so it's just kind of like but he
was like oh yeah it's like I got a
picture it's probably on my phone
somewhere I got it on my you on my
YouTube yeah
yeah I was bald then too I had shaved my
head for that
remember that's right that was a that
was a while back I'll find it yeah I'll
find that [__] I'll find that photo
that was a couple years ago oh it was a
long time ago yeah it wasn't a couple
years ago it was a long time ago that
was uh 10 years easily
huh I don't think it was that long no it
wasn't 10 years oh yeah had no it was no
it wasn't maybe seven it wasn't that
long ago
yeah bu Z says I was just telling my
wife that she's an author uh she's stuck
in that hospital with our baby at the
moment I'm I sent her a link I think
she'd get a kick out of your channel who
is this she's all bu Zach okay I think
she get a kick out of your channel she's
all rock crime and horror okay yeah yeah
oh [__] you'd love this [__] yeah I am
all about the true crime and the horror
I told you man I've been working on this
whole like history of horror video it's
just
like I'm hoping to get it up on New
Year's Day but we'll see how it goes
might be later but I'm excited about it
I'm excited about it I've spent like
ages and ages like writing this [__]
script for this for this thing I'm going
through the old photos I'm see if I find
they will make Foster
photo man there's so many pictures of me
and
you well and all the people we know
photograph us a lot yeah people
photograph us a lot thousands of [__]
cuties and [__] going back [__] 20
years
almost
uh man how am I gonna find Med Foster
and all this [__] well I don't
know
who's on there read read some
stuff bu act says yeah Meg Foster was in
a movie called
hellblazer yeah 22 no it wasn't that one
well we haven't seen that so it's just
like I kind of feel like like she was in
a lot of horror
stuff after that time
period so I kind of feel like I know
what you're saying you know what I mean
that it's just like you're thinking of
some other horror but she was absolutely
not in the first hell R I couldn't find
it I'm looking through here I can't find
it I thought she was in Hellraiser no I
have seen the first Hellraiser a zillion
bajillion times she is not in that I'm
looking through here and I don't [__]
see
her we had a picture of that I had a
picture I have a picture yeah of you and
Meg Foster yeah maybe you have the
picture maybe I I probably do yeah cuz
I'm I don't see it honestly it probably
is in my Dropbox
yeah in my pictures from phone folder
I'm finding these old pictures of me and
evil coneval oh I made
[Laughter]
that yeah Tom gave me an assignment yeah
to make a few years ago with me and evaa
when I was a little kid some pictures of
me yeah and make a whole thing so I
photoshopped
some awesome images yeah I'm gonna get
him of him as a little child talking to
evil Canal like giving him some pointers
whatnot it was [__] period correct
sure all right there's me as a little
kid in evil I'm discussing the snake
snake Mountain Canyon jump with evil
he's going I'm saying I think you can
make it evil evil and he's like yeah
well that dude better have that [__]
rocket cycle set up right and I was
telling him I said eville do not put
your hand on the [__] shoot release
[__] thing when you launch man and
he's like yeah I won't do that I mean
that's pretty good right yeah that looks
like me for just for just being
bullshitting yeah yeah Jen made all
kinds of photos of me me with the Goos
back when the Goos that was my favorite
one that was back when the Goos [__]
took me out as a [__] boy toy that
was my favorite one yeah I [__] y'all
don't know about this [__] that was
pretty good too yall don't know about
this [__] pretty good
too that's me with the Goos yeah yeah
that's me with the Goos see that turned
out nice I thought they [__] had me
on tour with them and [__] those
[__] used me up I can't believe it
all right I was out for [__] six
months with them on
tour and uh I got wore out I had to
[__] go back home I was thinking
about getting a lawyer and suing them
all all right oh yeah they took my
virginity did they really yes they did
those [__] who really took your
virginity yeah they didn't even love me
they they didn't love me I have to say
just as a Counterpoint yeah I met Jane
weedin yeah at a hor convention and she
is a delightful person yeah she's
delightful this is the
time when me and Adam Matt were hanging
out in
Brazil
look how good I did that [__] look how
good that is yeah I was like 15 and me
and Adam were me and Adam were [__]
partying and [__] Grace Jones came
and me and Adam was hitting it we we had
a threesome me Adam an and Grace Jones
it was a did you videotape it no we
didn't have videotape back then we
didn't have that [__] back then that's a
shame it was a it was intercial
threesome that's a shame 80s style yeah
that's a shame
yeah
this was the
time me
and me and Freddy
Mercury look at you yeah this a time me
and Freddy Mercury were doing [__] um
huge [__] show I don't remember
exactly what happened
though oh that's what you say right now
but okay this is the time right
here hold on where did that [__] go I
don't know okay here we go oh oh
I love this one
yeah this is the time me and David Bowie
okay did a duet we were sing Under
Pressure live okay at [__] you doing
the Freddy Mercury part yeah exactly
exactly exactly yeah me and Bowie
singing Under Pressure okay we did that
[__] live a just you guys forgot about
it
yeah my God
this is the time I was a cover boy up of
team
beat all right tiger be yeah was cover
boy tiger
be can we just acknowledge what's
that this [__] Photoshop skill yeah
she can
phot it was
awesome well you asking I had some
people believe in it
sure I tried to make it as realistic
yeah yeah yeah I had some people believe
in it it was and then we just posted
them without saying anything posted
those with my friends on [__] YouTube
without saying anything like
[__] yeah you didn't know no I didn't
know cuz Tom was like you know like yeah
like put this with and I was like okay I
can do that you didn't know I was a
cover boy I talker beat back in [__]
1981 1983 yeah yeah I like that one I
like that one yeah yeah it's a good one
a a lot of people bought that yeah they
bought it they bought that I looked good
I thought I did a good job I thought I
did a good job yeah she was [__]
funny just saying and they would ask me
questions and [__] and I come up with
some [__] crazy
[__] and these are people that do me
they're not they're like holy [__] Tom
that yeah yeah well you know what I mean
yeah no no J Cash photo no
no I didn't do a Jonah cash
one the ages wouldn't have worked out no
probably not we wanted to do stuff that
was like believable cuz Tom was like we
have to do stuff that people would
believe they might actually believe if
they saw it right so I had to be the
right age photo at the time I got you
I'm I'm going to do it like I was a
[__] eight-year-old [__]
consultant to [__] right to [__]
evil coneval about the Snake Canyon drum
you know I mean yeah cuz I was arounder
that time I'm G get into like
photoshopping do this [__] [__]
wearing the STP jumpsuit and [__] I
thought they came out very well I
thought the um the Goos one is my
favorite though yeah because I was very
happy yeah I found this photo of the
Goos and it was all the Goos and then
Belinda Carlile was at the end of the
photo like with her arm just out like
that like randomly me and berend and I
was like oh my God that's [__]
perfect
so I stole that photo and then I was
like I'm going to put Tom right in that
right in there although in reality I
wasn't that
old I know but it's but it worked it
looked so good cuz I was like this photo
of the go I'm like oh my God that's
amazing amazing in reality I would have
been about 13 at that
time and in the photo I'm more like 17
but you know close so the story that he
told yeah was that the Goos mhm had
taken him on tour with them I had a
story at the time but I forgot all about
it yeah ruined his well they took your
virginity that was that was the one
story yeah they kept running through me
right I was [__] anymore you couldn't
take it anymore I couldn't take it man I
was [__] helpless man all those women
they just kept I was young I couldn't
defend
myself and
then then just dropped me off terrible
used me up and dropped me off like a
[__] man the cat's in the
[__] she's she's in the [__] cat
box [__] throwing [__] Bambi is in
the litter box yeah she enjoys the
litter box I think she goes in there not
even doing what the litter box is
intended for but she just goes in there
to play yeah because I hear her in there
sometimes just throwing [__] around yeah
then I go in there earlier and there's
like [__] pellets everywhere so you
know yeah it must have been when I was
talk when I was talking to um Meg Foster
must have been talking to her about they
live cuz I remember I think I told her
look I was just watching that movie yeah
yeah cuz we had just seen I just talking
to her again like before we went to live
the convention yeah that's what I was
talking to her about I thought for it's
been a long time I thought it might have
been Hellraiser no I just said I just
saw I remember I just saw you a couple
weeks ago we were watching they live
said you did SC job like I remember that
yeah say you did a great job in that
movie it was it was a fun movie
she was thanking me but at the time I
was thinking of [__] also Masters of
the
Universe remember Masters of the
Universe a [__] sucky movie she
looked great in it it was shitty but she
looked great in it it's been a long time
since I've seen Master of the Universe I
think I saw it when it not when it first
came out I didn't go to the theater to
see that but like I think I saw it on
cable whenever it came out on cable yeah
I watched it then and I was just kind of
like all right well my younger brother
was way into the master of the universe
thing yeah you I got to put this away
it's going to die I'm a girl so I wasn't
really that I can get another one yeah
bring it okay bring
it Zach says Hellraiser freaked me out
as a child yeah um one of the things
interestingly one of the things that
made me want to be a horror writer I
started reading Stephen King um
just creepy mythology witch stories
vampire stories stuff like that when I
was a child like before I can even
remember but the thing that I
remember making me want to be a horror
writer was Clive Barker the first time
that I read books of blood when did that
come out I don't even remember like in
the 80s at some point and I was like
maybe a Preen or a
teenager and I read
that
and um I was like that's that's what I
want to do I want to write like that
[__] writes and I REM I remember
thinking um that that was the first time
that I really knew what I wanted to do
when I read Clyde Barker because I was
like I want to write like that dude
writes that is [__] up like the [__]
that he came up with I was like that is
[__] awesome like I had been reading
Stephen King for a couple years and that
was like cool too but Clyde Barker
that's like another level he was
perverted that yeah and it's just like
he was like that was another level so I
read that when I was probably too young
to be reading that but nobody was
policing
me but I read books of blood when I was
a kid and I was just like man this is
[__] up it's like this this is what I
want to do I this kind of [__] when I
when I was younger man I read this one
book that where I think it was CDE
Barker you you'll correct me cuz you'll
remember who it
was it's about a guy who did time in
prison and when he was in prison he lost
his girlfriend and when he got out he
was working for this rich guy it turned
out he was in this [__] Mansion where
Sorcerers and [__] were having sex with
[__] animals and the spirits of
animals and humans and [__] there was
[__] coming from the other world and
they were like hybrids of animal and
human spirits and [__] remember that one
that sounds Clyde Barker E I think it
can't remember which one it was I
remember which movie what what book it
was was [__] bizarre the guy who
wrote it was a the guy who the story is
being told from the point of view of a
guy who got out of prison and and worked
I think as some kind of a [__]
right-hand man or groundkeeper to a
[__] billionaire who was in charge of
a [__] sex cult might be oh [__] was
in charge of a sex cult and they were
doing weird [__] I'll you a second they
were doing all this weird [__] in the
sex coat they tried to get him into it
to have sex with him and then the guy
was making fun of him saying now yeah
you know you uh you poor guys [__]
normies are real [__] vanilla when it
comes to sex and [__] and then
he's he's I think some of the [__] he
was seeing in the past I don't remember
how it's been a long time since I read
it some of the [__] he been seen in the
past some of it was happening in the
present but I remember it was like
people having sex with each other and
demons and animals sure and then their
Spirits were in the other world of the
animals and the demons and the spirits
were having sexy they were and they were
having
Offspring okay that were sometime
popping over into this world where they
might be half part human part demon and
part animal
do you remember what what book that was
not entirely sure it could have been a
lot of things well like I said 30 years
when I first read Clyde Barker I think
the thing
that resonated me with me the most um
the short story in the Hills the
cities uh which was either from the
first books of blood or the second one I
can't really remember but it was a whole
thing where the there were two cities
that were Rivals yeah and every now and
again they would get together and like
fight but they wouldn't just like get
together and fight like normal they
would each City would get together and
strap to one another into a big
giant thing but it was people but they
were all kind of like strapping together
into this
big thing like like a monster Okay and
like then the other one would do that
too so it was all these people that were
strapped together as an entity and they
would fight each other like a big me
like a city like a big ver a city but it
was all humans yeah and it's just kind
of like when I read that I was a kid
when I read that and that blew my
[__] mind I'm like that is [__]
awesome that's great I Lov that I love
that so it's just like all these people
they're just regular people they didn't
have superpowers or anything like that
but they were just like all you know
kind of like um you know put themselves
together into one big like I said like a
Mecca yeah but not mechanical they
didn't have any special powers or
anything it was just like a bunch of
power like a bunch of people yeah all in
one thing and it's like and then they
would fight each other and I'm just like
oh my God I love that I love that idea I
just love that um so the fact that he
could come up with this crazy [__]
[__] and I read a bunch of this other
stuff too but that was the one that made
the biggest impression the fact that he
come up with his [__] and then like
later on I read like um like some of his
other novels like weave World which was
kind of like
um everything being it's it's kind of
hard to explain but it's just kind of
like this whole thing being like a a
woven of all of reality being like a
woven rug kind of but everything was
kind of like interconnected like you
could kind of see it from over you know
what I mean so it so like I said it's
kind of hard to explain but um but that
whole [__] concept really I was like
man this [__] dude the [__] he comes
up with I love that it's like I want to
do that I think Clyde Parker like I read
Stephen King from a young age probably
younger than I should have
but um and I loved it cuz I was into
horror from um as long as I can remember
I I love creepy [__] so I love Stephen
King but [__] like that but reading
Clyde
Barker that was the thing that like I
want to do that I want to write that
kind of [__] up [__] I want to write
that [__] that's what made me want to be
a horror writer every everything I read
was [__] perverted like that yeah
well the the [__] the Catal
check well yeah I got to read more of
your stuff but you should yeah I just
been so busy you know what I mean
[__] you should read me some of that
[__] do you want me to yeah but you're
always working look she is always
[__] working she if you want me to
ask me all right I'll read you all my
stor well do you have any of that [__]
on
audiobook all my stuff's on audiobook
okay yeah except for the newest stuff
that I've written all right well not
what I'll do is I I'll get just send me
the [__] links to that to the codes
and I'll [__] listen to this [__]
yeah I've like I've read all of my stuff
yeah super like you haven't listened to
Jenny stuff no I listened to some of it
but I haven't listened to all of it it's
not crazy crazy like read like I've read
a lot of extreme horror yeah and a lot
of my stuff isn't that she produces a
lot of stuff just not only these these
books but just the shows and everything
she she's highly prodigious so I can't
keep I love the [__] I love the [__]
right you know I love the [__] yeah I'm
not a
fanboy I'm not wither because of the
[__] what I love her so you know what
I mean [__] they got dudes that are
fanboys on her you know it's it's a
different situation for us well you just
love me as a person yeah I think
yeah other than we've had nothing but
fun together for [__] 15 years like I
said and that that's the thing you don't
really like you've read some of my stuff
I've read some of yeah it was like Clyde
Barker kind of harder
from what I read yeah I mean I like to
well I've seen the reaction of friends
of ours to some of the [__] she's like
man you are
gross damn not all my [__] is gross I
don't do like extreme horror but I do
kind of like experiment with yeah I was
like cuz sometimes I'm just like I would
like to write a story that I would like
to it you know if I read it that would
make me throw up yeah so it's just kind
of like I'm going to write a story like
that so I've written a story like that
but most of the stuff that I write most
of the stuff that I write comes from a
point of view of I love horror I've seen
a lot of horror so I'm just kind of like
I want to do something in this vein but
with a totally different angle to it
that nobody's thought of or that I think
nobody's thought of I want to come at it
from a different come here angle that's
all yeah I don't want to redo something
that somebody has already done that's
the only thing that I'm trying to
avoid uh when I'm writing stuff look who
it is oh it's Pokey it's
Pokey she's like
um what am I doing on
the well it's getting kind of late Jen
want to go ahead and shut it down um
wait a minute I guess but it's just kind
of like okay yeah Jeffy said I was more
of a shirra kind of guy what what
happened she was biting Spock why did
you bite Spock don't bite SP don't bite
Spock no she got like all in
trouble Zach says imagine doing the chat
right now joining the chat right now
yeah well we kind of think of that I
don't know if we think of that but every
episode that is kind of the case because
once you get the drunker we get the
crazier the [__] gets yeah this is open
lines so [__] Friday is like is super
we don't have a topic we're just like
talking about whatever we don't worry
about it being monetized most of the
audience is getting drunk too so sure so
we're not like kind of worried about it
um Jeffy says I loved Clive Barker's
night breed as a concept it was great as
a novel novela I guess which was called
cabal um it was like X-Men as a horror
Adventure sad they never had a sequel um
I didn't love the movie I kind of feel
like Clive
Barker other than the first Hellraiser
which was amazing um he didn't really
have a
good track record of his stuff being
translated well to screen even when he
directed himself he directed the first
Hellraiser which was awesome like I said
but everything that he directed after
that including night breed and Lord of
of Illusions were not great I will argue
that the best other than
Hellraiser the best Clyde Barker
adaptation was Candyman from 1992 which
was not directed by him it was directed
by Bernard Bros it was based on a short
story of his which was called The
Forbidden but that was a great great
[__]
movie
Clyde Barker other than Hellraiser I
kind of feel like his directorial
efforts have not
been um all that fruitful which is kind
of sad because Clyde
Barker he seems like a massively
talented individual like his writing is
a [__] amazing he's an amazing artist
but making movies that's a totally
different skill set let's say that what
did did he make those movies or just
right straight he made Hellraiser okay
which is amazing yeah um I thought it
was kind of dry actually no I love
Hellraiser yeah but the other movies he
directed he directed well he wrote rawad
Rex which let's I actually like draw
head Rex [__] it was a classic it's a
good story he wrote the story not well
exe executed well like I said I don't
want to blame Clyde for that he was just
kind of like look I wrote the story one
of the reasons that he wanted to direct
Hellraiser himself which was a year
later was
because rad Rex didn't turn out the way
he wanted he's like I wrote the story it
was a different director he's like
didn't love it the problem with Raad Rex
was the way the monster was the special
effect special that's all it was I yeah
was a good Irish movie good Irish
[__] horror movie with a crazy ass
[__] monster in it it had some real
good [__] Concepts in
it me and my Fred Jason back in
Michigan um [__] watched that [__] we
were in high
school and the whole concept of the
[__] evil priest that was bringing
the rawhead reck back into the world and
him being baptized and [__] by [__]
Raad pissing on him and everything we
thought that [__] was great and then the
[__] magical [__] it's a great
idea a lot of [__] that was really good
about that if you're going to remake
something please remake that yeah you
could remack Road Rex it be awesome man
you could do some awesome [__] with that
yeah yeah the road Rex monster in the
[__] it would look so because the
monster in it was cool but it the eyes
didn't move it was 96 or 97 whatever it
end being kind of [__] up looking but
we we laughed at it in high school but
we still liked it we still like the
spookiness of that movie there were some
great [__] ideas in that like I said
yeah it was a cult classic yeah we we
liked it I still like have uh a lot of
fondness for that movie even though it's
terrible objectively but it still like
has some fondness to it it was fun it is
fun and uh afterwards we were thinking
about yeah man wonder if that wonder if
something like that would really exist
you know we're high school you know fing
and we're like yeah yeah that's some fre
[__] man I you know we might go into a
[__] we might go into to a church one
day and see some weird I mean you never
know you see some weird [__] you know
what I mean stained glass window that
has a demon in it that's some weird [__]
yeah yeah yeah D it just it was it was a
movie of the time yeah a movie of but
you could update that I think I kind of
feel like that's one of the movies like
I said they shouldn't remake stuff that
was good to start with yeah don't remake
Texas chainsaw master M for example
don't remake The Exorcist don't don't
like remake [__] that was like good the
first time if you're going to remake
something remake some [__] that was a
good idea that wasn't executed but was
poorly executed or they didn't like
really have the money to do it or
something like that like please like
that's really what it was it wasn't that
it was done wrong they didn't have the
money yeah that's kind of what I so I
didn't really like give him some of the
[__] was cool I mean [__] rawh head
is running around that's a great idea
it's a great idea killing [__]
killing poor Irish people in the trailer
park and all and I was like yeah that's
awesome man they were making out [__]
rawhead Rex kill it's a great idea good
idea yeah yeah had the monster looked
better yeah yeah had the monster looked
better had the monster been on par with
say like pumpkin
head it would it would have it would
have been great pumpkin head did look
but Stan Winston did that [__] to be
fair so
um yeah
uh what I saw something earlier that I
want oh Danny Rowling said uh night
breed and midnight me train are my
favorite Barker films midnight me train
was great that was actually one of my
favorite um Barker stories from the old
days and the fact that they made that
into like a decent film to be fair that
was like not hard to do because that was
more of like a it wasn't
[Music]
um not super Supernatural it was just
more of a serial killer type of thing um
so it was like easier to execute I guess
I feel like the problem with Clive
Barker is that he's so
imaginative that a lot of his stuff
doesn't translate well to film yeah
because if you see it on
film um it doesn't look as cool as you
would like it imagined it like when you
were reading it and I thought that too
when I was reading a lot of his stuff is
just like his stuff is just so out there
that if you try
to visualize it if you try
to you know make it into a story and
stuff like that it's just not going to
work it's not going to work so I kind of
feel like like no [__] on Clyde Barker
because I love him he's one of my heroes
he's the dude that made me want to be a
horror writer like I said Stephen King I
read all his stuff I loved all his stuff
but it was Clyde Barker when I read his
stuff that I was like this is what I
want to do I want to write like this
[__] but a lot of his stuff is
just
so crazy that if you try to make it into
a movie it's not going to work yeah
murder Hornets in the comments ask me to
watch his movie I for murder Hornet is a
friend of mine he's a VA guy like me
[__] lives on the Mexican border and
he he thinks he's Hano he's jumping
across hor got a okay and he was in a
Mexican movie he sent me the link to it
py where he was in the Mexican he's in
the Mexican movie movies about all kinds
of Mexican cartels and he's in a big
gunfight gets killed in the Mexican
movie I seen the movie [__] see let
me see the name of the movie again hold
on hold on it's
called el preo de the price of power
it's the Mexican [__] flick let me
see I'm going
show murder Hornet I'm going go ahead
and [__] plug your movie okay hold on
let me
see the price of
power [__] murder Hornet is always
sending me some [__] bizarre [__]
cartel videos of them [__] killing
people skinny dudes alive and [__] any
kind of [__]
hardcore [__]
Cartel movie [__] this is
it
a yeah murder hornet in that movie he's
in a [__] big gunfight in there gets
killed he says the mix movie I was in
[__]
yeah he sent me all kind of [__]
videos over time and the cartel [__]
he gets a hold of them those Mexican
cartels and um there was one
where they get some guy and they get him
[__] high on [__] me on
[__] what's that [__]
drug they get this they drug this dude
up and they [__] scin him alive and
[__] what are you talking about
murder Hornet the damn cartel execution
video he sent me I couldn't watch that
[__] man they [__] skinn that dude
alive and [__] cut his throat pulled
the tongue out and [__] it was some
bizarre [__]
man why are we so bright those D what's
that why are we so bright I was just
showing the movie oh that that uh so you
[__] up the Lan that he was in I'm
[__] it up this is what you're talking
okay there we go
yeah yeah what was I talking about
before I don't
remember it's getting late Jen we've
been on here for [__] almost it's
quarter a minute yeah five hours
almost bu a says you should watch from
if you haven't seen it made by the lost
people I don't know that one um I've
heard of that but I haven't watched it
yet I haven't watched it
yet
yeah that right yeah just go and shut it
down I'm tired yeah let's get something
something to eat too you hungry yeah
starving all right all right so
hopefully you guys have a good New
Year's weekend we'll be on Monday night
yeah for New Year's Day talking about
some movie probably little big man yeah
yeah but it I don't know maybe something
if you guys haven't seen little big man
go see little big man it's free on um
with Dustin Hoffman yeah Dustin Hoffman
it's free on uh Amazon Prime if you have
Amazon Prime it's a [__] great 1970 I
think it was it's a great yeah somewhere
Western where uh little big man's about
a guy who's both a cowboy and an
Indian he even meets kuster uh he
[__] gets in gang bang with a [__]
bunch of Indian chicks the whole it's an
awesome flick forgotten flick funny as
[__] kind of kind of
historical it's good though Loosely
Loosely Loosely yeah loosely I kind of
uh it's up there with Jeremiah Johnson
although I would say Jeremiah Johnson's
kind of better more epic but yeah yeah
yeah I'd age but little big man's fcking
ENT very entertaining good to it is very
funny yeah so we might talk about that
or if we see something else over the
weekend that strikes our fancy we might
be talking about that but uh hopefully
you guys have a good weekend coming up
and a good New Year's Day because that's
what's coming up and uh thank you
everybody for your support thank you
everybody for giving us super and uh you
can give us a super thanks too if you're
listening to this uh recording Zach says
oh wow you're still going yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah we're about to we just get
ready get off tune out though we got to
go eat I'm starting but uh but yeah so
hopefully you guys have a good time this
Friday evening we will see you guys
again on Monday night good night